(gentle music)
Most addictions thrive in secrecy.
That's it. I'm telling you.
It's the secret is the killer.
(gentle upbeat music)
When I started to voice that I had an addiction,
I started to voice what the pornography thing was.
And I started to talk. It loses its power.
Shame can't survive the light.
It can't, it's like exposing the germs to sunlight.
That's one reason why I'm so vulnerable,
'cause I don't want any secrets.
I tell the whole story and man, I'm in control.
Hey everybody. Welcome to the podcast.
Today, we're gonna talk about strength.
We're gonna talk about power, but not the physical kind.
I'm talking about the mental and emotional kind.
(gentle music)
It's a conversation about masculinity,
both toxic and healthy.
It's about overcoming obstacles, how to confront your past,
own your path and ultimately step into your truest power
and most self-actualized self.
Our guide for this journey is former NFL linebacker,
lifelong artists and star of screens,
big and small, Terry Crews.
So you know this guy, you may know him from "Idiocracy,"
the Expendables movies, "Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
"Everyone Hates Chris," "America's Got Talent,"
or one of his many other projects.
You're also likely familiar with Terry's insane physique,
his incredible charm, but beneath it all is actually
a guy who's endured a litany of uncommon hardships
and really struggled immensely for the better part
of his life to control his relationships,
his image as a tough guy, his experiences with racism,
all of which led to this destructive spiral
that he endured and ultimately a path forward,
a path that has given him a new perspective and really
a new life, all of which is elegantly
and powerfully chronicled
in his new book out this week entitled
"Tough: My Journey to True Power."
Today, we cover it all.
And in addition to this being an incredible human
and a powerful storyteller, Terry was remarkably frank.
He was very generous with his time
and this conversation is just fantastic.
So please click that subscribe button
and hit that notification and let's do it.
This is me and Terry Crews.
Well, you got a lot going on.
I appreciate you taking the time to do this,
especially on Saturday, man.
I'm excited for you.
The new book is coming out lots to talk about,
and you know, to kind of kick things off.
I was thinking about how to approach this conversation
with you and thinking about what this show is about.
And, you know, I talked to lots of different people across,
you know, a multiplicity of specialties and expertise,
but if there is one kind of core theme
it's transformation, like how do you weather obstacles?
How do you persevere and grow and evolve and share
what you learned along the way like in service
to other people?
And as much as anybody that I know, you truly embody
this ethos, not just, you know, in the many pivots
across the course of your life and the many challenges
that you faced and overcome, but this, you know,
transparency that you have around expansion
into self-authenticity and how you show up in the world
in service is really the heart of kind
of what I love to talk about and what you're all about.
So I'm really excited to talk to you today.
Thank you. Thank you.
So why don't we start with, you know,
the subject matter of the book, which is really
this journey from what we could kind of, I mean,
this term is played out, toxic masculinity,
but this journey from, you know, being sort
of the embodiment of toxic masculinity to this,
you know, person who, who could be characterized
as very much self-actualized in many ways.
I mean, we're all on our journey.
There's always, the more you grow,
the more you realize how much more there is to grow.
That's right.
But why don't we start there and, you know,
maybe talk a little bit about masculinity
and how you're thinking about it.
Yeah.
You know, and you're right in the regard
that the phrase toxic masculinity has been played out.
It's just, right now, it's been so overused
and misrepresented and all this stuff.
But now the phrase that I like to use is abuse of power.
And, you know, one thing for me, you know,
in growing up and my, to give you some context
and some background is that, you know,
I grew up in Flint, Michigan in 1968.
That was when I was born and, you know,
Flint, Michigan was Palo Alto.
It was the premier young, vibrant city.
General Motors was the number one corporation in the world.
It was the Google of its generation.
So everyone was doing very, very well.
And they made a lot of promises,
a lot of promises to the citizens, to the families.
And I mean, you could go there.
My father moved up from a little town
in Edison, Georgia that was only 300 people,
and he moved up to join the factory.
Like most of my family did on both sides from my mom's side
and my father's side, they all came up from Georgia
because of the promise of all these jobs and all this stuff.
And so it was a lot of hope.
It was, I mean, my early days,
it seemed like the city was growing and big events
and all this stuff.
And then all of a sudden, when I turned around nine or 10,
in the late '70s things started to change.
And I mean very, very quickly.
And you know, the whole,
the auto industry was going down.
The, you know, everything, the foreign cars started
to come into play, into the picture.
And a lot of people don't remember this,
but I do there used to be like small smoke stacks
going up around the city.
And what they were doing was burning foreign cars
in the lots.
Like if you brought Toyota into the city and people
would surround it and burn it in effigy.
Wow. And I've come from Detroit.
So I know, you know, I know that vibe,
like you ain't driving a foreign car.
You remember that?
I think it's still that way in Detroit.
Oh yeah. I mean, it's wild.
I didn't see a foreign car until I joined the NFL
and moved out to LA and I was like,
that's a Mercedes, right?
Wow. Like that's a BMW.
You know what I mean?
Because it was just foreign.
It was crazy.
But on top of this, on top of these small changes
that were happening, there was things going on in my house.
My father was extremely abusive.
One of my earliest memories, like when I four
or five years old, I remember my father knocking
my mother out, you know, right there in the living room.
And I can't describe the helplessness I felt
because, you know,
my father was a giant.
I mean, he had these big giant...
My hands are big, but he had these big calloused,
giant man hands.
And he would walk around the house with this boom, boom.
You know, the way he walked and the way he moved
and the way he did everything, it was just,
it was like watching a giant and this force
and when he would hit my mother and I saw her on the ground,
I was like, got it. That's the rules.
We run it. Men run it.
And this is the lesson I had.
That's in regards to masculinity, it was like,
yo, you control everything.
He controlled our household.
It wasn't a thing where, you know, I felt the love
of my father, but I felt the possessiveness of my father.
I felt like something he owned
and he owned his family and it was and he made sure that we,
it was a little bit, for him,
he'd rather be feared than loved, you know.
And he never really gave any bit of,
he never really showed any,
what would be called vulnerability.
It was always solid, hardcore.
This is the way I am.
This is, you know, everything was military-like
and brutal in judgment, you know,
which it was,
I mean, I literally, I remember just holding my breath,
when he was around.
Right.
On top of that, you have the alcoholism and you talk
about in the book the morning, dad and the night dad.
Yes.
Trying to connect with your dad in the morning,
but that fear when he would pull up in the driveway
at night, not knowing what you were gonna get
and all of that.
But I also appreciated in the book
how you painted a broader picture of who this man was,
rather than just kind of characterize him
as the abusive alcoholic, right?
Like this was a guy who like, despite everything
would put himself together in the morning, would polish
his shoes, was trying to find some modicum of pride.
Yep.
In this factory job that he had.
And this idea that a lot of the, you know,
quote unquote toxic masculinity aspects of who he was
were driven by a sense of powerlessness
when the factories were drying up and the jobs
were going away, and all of that.
Yep.
Like it's more nuanced
than just saying he was A, B and C.
Exactly.
And listen, the thing is, my dad made it.
Like from where he came from, it was a thing where, wow,
like he, he was a symbol of pride.
Everyone who was back home was like, man, you did it.
His father, once I got into my past and I learned,
and it took me, listen, in the course of writing this book,
I found out more about my past than I ever knew
in my 54 years on Earth, right?
That's maybe my favorite part of the whole book.
When you trace that later in the book.
Oh, it's so special.
It is so amazing because, but, you know,
one thing I learned is his father, you know,
was on a chain gang in Georgia, in the heat,
in 100-degree humidity of Georgia, he committed
a few crimes and was convicted to, you know, serving
on a chain gang.
And he, as a child had to pass his own dad
on the school bus, knowing that his dad
was out there tied to other prisoners, working on the roads.
And I'm like, these are the kind of things
that was driving me to drink.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
These are the kind, that's the kind of pain
that he could never articulate, that he couldn't understand.
And his father died when he was 17 years old
and he never got over it, you know,
'cause his father basically abandoned the family.
And so when you're talking about this kind
of deep, deep thing, and this is another thing,
and I got in trouble a little bit about this, you know,
early on, especially on the internet, but you know,
my dad needed his father.
And a lot of times, you know, I know my purpose on Earth,
you know, but what's wild is that I've had people tell me
that fatherhood is not necessary,
and I'm going, but you wouldn't say that about motherhood.
You know, and I'm telling you
from my own personal experience, I needed my dad.
And they go, well, no, you know,
that is if two parents love each other, it's all good.
And then what was happening is especially
in the black community, you know, the issue of,
you know, there being no fathers is directly tied
in to a lot of the problems that the community has.
I mean, you know, black men are 6%
of the American population yet make up more than 40%
of the homicide victims, right?
Which is unreal, which is a problem,
which is what you would call a catastrophe.
And I think there are parallels to the fact
that there the fatherlessness in that community,
in our community, it ties in to the violence.
It ties in to when you don't have a dad around
you go right to the gangs, you go right to those vices.
You go right to all those things, because you do need,
you need someone to guide you, to show you what being
a man is like, and when we're talking
about masculinity, you know?
That's the question.
Right, and also
the epigenetics of generation
after generation repeating, you know,
like sort of patterns that don't work and kind of
calcifying this idea of what it means to be a man,
because they're repeating the patterns of their father,
even if that father was present in the household,
like in your case, who was your model
for how to be a man in the world?
It's a guy who was completely locked down emotionally.
That's right.
But I appreciated the attempt to try to understand
him as a guy who was also caught between the white world
and the black world.
That's right.
He was too advanced in the factory
to be accepted by, you know, the guys on the floor, right?
Who were predominantly black.
Sure. Yep.
But he wasn't quite in the C-suite
to be accepted by the white guys.
So he had his own like kind of identity crisis
that he was trying to navigate simultaneously.
You know, a lot of people just,
what is really, really hardcore in his walk
was that here he was, he was trying to make it
and he felt like he was doing the right thing,
and then what was crazy is that he was ridiculed
by his peers just for advancing,
which is another problem, you know.
And then when you advance, the people who, you know,
kind of hold the key to your future
wouldn't accept him completely,
simply because he was one of the few black foreman
in the place.
So you had tons of white foreman all around
and they would go on up the ladder.
He being a black foreman kind of was stuck
in his place 'cause he wouldn't get invited
to the inner city, I mean the inner parties.
Right.
Or the inner sector, you know what I mean?
And then the blacks who were on the floor were just like,
oh, he's a sellout.
And what's wild is that there's a, you know,
there's a phrase that blacks use, you know,
to describe what they would call, you know,
black people who sell out, and it's a coon.
And they look at you capitulating to,
you know, the white world in order to be accepted
and what you're doing, you know,
you're doing what you have to do to make it.
And that's a hard role.
And he took these things personally and a good thing
is I'm smart enough and have learned enough to know,
to let that just, you know, for me, you know,
these kind of insults are just like, okay,
that has more to do with you than it does with me.
But back in that time and that period,
there wasn't that kind of introspection,
you know what I mean?
It was just like, why am I not being accepted
by my own people?
You know? And he was very angry.
Like it just created this really toxic anger.
So you have this unhealthy role model in the household.
Meanwhile, the jobs are drying up.
There's white flight, the gangs are coming in.
That's right.
So you go to school and you went to Flint Academy,
which was like kind of the best place for you to go, right?
But not a lot of great role models there either, right?
A lot of temptations.
I mean, you could have easily,
like there's so many inflection points in your story
and in your life, I mean, you could have easily gone down
a dark alley with the whole gang thing.
Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I have to, because now on the flip side,
my mother was extremely religious,
which is a whole nother aspect.
Right.
Yeah, that's a whole other section of the book, too.
I mean, we deal on all these topics
and I kind of was right in the middle of all this stuff
with the religion, you know, I was not allowed
to go to secular movies,
listen to secular music, go dance,
go to play sports.
Everything I ended up doing and being in my life,
I was not allowed to do as a kid.
But we're about the same age.
So we both remember well
that first experience of going to "Star Wars."
Yes.
And for you, that was like this transgressive act.
Listen, I begged.
My mother was not going to let us go.
The religion that we were in,
it was so strict.
And so shame-based and everything was just, you know,
the thing is you could go to hell at any moment.
That was the through lie.
Like anything send you to help.
Okay, so going to a movie, oh no, you're gonna go to hell,
you do that, you know?
And I begged my mother and she wouldn't let me go.
And we were just like,
and I couldn't, 'cause we could go to school
and you hear people talking, this is days
when a movie was four-walled.
So a movie would be in the theaters for a year, right?
You know, like now it's like,
it's out in three weeks, you know what I mean?
But it was, would be in the movie for a year,
two years, and still be out.
And I would hear the kids in school just, oh, "Star Wars,"
and they'd be talking about different parts.
And I'm like, oh my God, I just gotta see this.
And the anticipation,
I just wanted to see it so bad.
And my aunt, thank God she came through and she said,
and my mother's name was Patricia.
She said, "Trish, you gotta let these kids see this movie."
You know, like, "I'm gonna take them, okay?
Can I take them?"
And she just broke like, "All right, go ahead."
And I said...
And it changed my life forever.
I'll never forget that drive in, seeing, watching that.
We all remember that first screen.
That John Williams score hit,
ah, you know what I mean?
Yeah. Yeah.
It was it.
So how does your mom square,
like, what you're doing now with that mindset?
Well, my mom passed away 2015,
but she also left.
She was alive long enough to-
Yes. She left the church.
She left that version of what the church was
when I was probably in high school.
And she went to a less restrictive version of Christianity.
But I like to call it a cult.
I mean, it was, it was very cultish in all its ways
when you're talking about rules and all this stuff.
So she kind of moved on from that and grew
into loving what I was doing.
You know, what's wild is that she kind of saw the light
as we moved on, and I got more popular and started doing
things she started to understand, but she, you know,
she loved what I did at the end.
One thing is she always, always loved entertainment,
like always.
And she had-
She had the subscriptions
to all the magazine.
Exactly.
People Magazine and all that kind of stuff. (laughs)
Well, I worked hard to rectify,
like to try to figure out what that was like.
We can't go to the movies, but we love the movies.
We can't do this, but we love this.
And it was, so I used to read her People
and Entertainment magazines, and the whole thing.
And one thing we did together though,
was we would sit and watch "The Carol Burnett Show."
I'll never forget, every Saturday night.
And it was the highlight, highlight of my life,
because first of all, you know, I'll never forget.
My mom was nursing a black eye that my dad gave her.
And she had like this, it was some frozen peas
or something on her eye.
And we would just sit and watch Carol Burnett
and laugh and laugh.
And then after it was over, I would repeat
some of the skits and she would just laugh at me doing
some of the skits, the Tim Conway and Harvey Korman,
and all this stuff.
And I'll never forget that.
I mean, even to this day, I view that as my first step
in what I'm doing now was the attempt
to make my mother laugh through all the pain
she was going through.
Yeah.
Well, there's this split in who you are
for the better part of your life.
Like on the one hand, you're this alpha athlete,
guy's going in the weight room, trying to get big
and strong to deal with what's going on at home
and to deal with the sort
of social stratification of school.
But at the same time, you're a kid who's sensitive
and likes comic books and is really good at drawing and art,
which, you know, creates this tension in like, who am I?
Who is Terry Crews?
And how am I showing up in the world?
Like these two things kind of at war with each other.
It was at war.
And what was wild is that,
you know, I remember,
you know, having to fight my way into school.
It was, you know, the gangs, the drug dealers,
the people that were around me
were always looking at me suspiciously.
They would say things like you talk white, you know.
And I'm like, what is that?
And what was happening is, remember,
I was kind of sheltered, is what it was.
I mean, I was religious.
I was in this thing where they wouldn't allow us
to do anything, but so I would go into my hole
and I would draw and draw all day.
I mean, I would draw what I wanted to see, you know,
and it was a introspective, very nerdy world.
I became this nerd.
But then when I came outside, I was always challenged on it.
Like, oh man, you, this is, you know,
back in the day, they called you a square, you know.
And it was like, what?
But then athletics coded black, coded hardcore.
So I said, all right.
So I have to be that, you know, and I knew
that I had to be big, strong, fast, athletic,
and they would leave me alone.
You know, it's like, I knew when I got some traps
that they would think twice about they'd go, well,
he's probably gonna do some athletic stuff,
so they leave him alone.
But the skinny kid, he had no choice.
They would beat him up.
It would be crazy. It would be violent.
They used to beat up my brother.
He was smaller than I was.
He's my half-brother.
And I remember these gang members
threw him in the rose bush, and he was just hurt.
We went home and he was in tears and I was just like,
pulling him out of it, like, but they didn't mess with me.
Yeah.
But that coded black and it coded hardcore.
You know what I mean?
But it's almost like this shield, this armor
that you built around yourself simply
to protect that artist within you.
Yeah.
So he could still, you know, do his thing quietly
without, you know, being bullied or taking the task.
I always knew that I was what you would call weird,
you know, in that respect, 'cause it, people were always,
they would just tell me, "Man, you weird, man," you know?
And I'm, "Hey," you know, "whatever, I don't..."
I would just kind of blink it off.
And this is another thing is that I would fake it.
You know, a lot of my acting ability, you know,
one thing I used to do is dumb down.
It was, oh man, I don't know what y'all talking about,
man, what you doing, man?
Yeah, you know,
and you just learned to mirror the lingo and the mirror.
I would mirror people so that they wouldn't be suspicious.
You know what I mean?
Like get along to go along?
It was get, and then go home.
And then all of a sudden find somebody who,
or even be at school and find somebody
who we had the same, you know, interest.
And it was like, oh man, I could go all in on this.
You know what I mean?
And it was funny 'cause even when I met my wife, she said,
"I thought you were the biggest nerd.
And I saw you with your friend
and you talked a whole different way.
And I was like, ah, that's kind
of how I'm doing my whole life.
You know, I knew 'cause she was like
"Here I'm thinking you're this nerdy black guy.
And then I turn around and you're with these guys,
your friends, you're talking all cool.
And I was like, just like two people."
And I was like, yeah, it had to be that way
my whole life.
Yeah.
But this idea blossoms into this notion that
this is the case for all men.
Doesn't don't all men have two lives,
the secret life that they hide from everybody else,
and then the way that they show up in the world?
That's right.
That's just the way it is.
It is. I believe that.
I believe that. That was definitely the case for me.
Yeah.
So without any kind of healthy role models
for yourself as a young person, you strike this vow
with your friend, which I think is super interesting.
It's it's almost like a survival tactic.
Like, Hey no one's showing us the way,
like we gotta help each other out.
Yeah.
I mean, I remember coming to my friend,
my best friend in the world, his name was Darwin and I said,
"Hey man."
I said, "Dude, no one how no one is telling us anything."
And we had nothing but questions and we would try,
we would ask, and all-
The men wouldn't give it up.
They would literally, "You gonna find out."
"Hey, lemme tell you something. You gonna find out, homie."
You know, and you're like, oh man, what?
And it's like, dude, I'm 11.
Can you please just gimme some clues?
And then what was wild is that we would get
all this erroneous information.
Like what the things they did volunteer was like,
"Hey man, look what you want to do.
You wanna take these girls tell 'em you love them,
get the drawers and then bounce."
And I was like, "But what if you do like 'em?"
"No, no, you don't love 'em. You can't love them."
And you're like, what are you talking about?
Like it did 'cause I had this vision of actual love.
Like, I mean there's picture, like even in the movies,
like there's people fall in love though, right?
They're like, "No man, what you want to do.
You gotta have like four or five and you gotta keep 'em on,
and you gotta always keep 'em on a leash
and then call 'em and then don't call 'em back."
I mean, and the whole phrase was called game.
And it still talked about even now, you know.
And it was like, you gotta have game to run this thing.
And you gotta have all these girls, you gotta have 10.
And the more you had, the more of a man you were.
And I was like...
And that's again, the message of what masculinity
was was that you were a pimp,
and that's what I grew up with.
And it was like, but I said,
"But I don't, (sighs) I just..."
You know, and I had a really, really hard time
because I said, I don't really wanna lie to people.
And then I escaped into porn and that was the only,
because my parents never, my father to this day
has never had a conversation with me about sex ever.
And my mother was so religious.
She was like, "Are you having sex?"
And I'm like, "No, I'm not."
"Don't don't do it.
I'm trying, listen, you know, you go to hell, right?"
And like, "Okay."
Back to hell again, you know?
(both men laugh)
And so I totally avoided that conversation.
But so everything I learned was at nine years old,
when I went over my uncle's house, opened up his chest
and it was full of pornographic magazines.
And you know, a lot of people, you know,
what's wild about that is that everybody says,
well, you know, pornography is great.
You know, it's totally acceptable
when people are over 18, the whole thing.
But I don't know anybody
that ever encountered pornography at 18.
No. Yeah.
You know, you always encounter it in school
or whatever, when someone's showing you
and you're like six, seven, eight, nine.
I mean, and it's damaging. It's damaging.
It really is.
And we grew up in a time where it was,
you know, in a box that your friend's dad had
in the basement somewhere or buried in the woods
or some shit like that.
Right.
You know, and now it's like ubiquitous
and so readily available, and unlimited
and it's fucking crazy.
I can't. Listen, man.
The thought of what kids are possibly looking at right now,
it send chills down my back.
Yeah.
Chills.
And 'cause I know where it's what path it set me on.
And again, man, you know, people have said,
well, you can't, I don't think you can be addicted
to pornography and the whole thing.
But my problem was is that, hey man, if day turns into night
and you're still watching it and you say you don't want to
and you keep doing it,
I don't know what else to call it.
But I found even as a young kid, what happened
is when I discovered it took all my problems away.
I mean, when I open that magazine,
I didn't even know what I was looking at mind you,
I didn't even know how to have sex,
but I just knew, oh my God, this is mind blowing.
You know, and I was totally numbed out
and I forgot about the violence.
I forgot about my dad, and I forgot about the religiosity.
And then, well, what happened is I would get shame
and you feel, oh Lord, I know I'm going to hell.
I'm going to hell.
And so you would say, I'll be good. I'll be good.
And I became a performer.
I became this person who wanted to keep peace in the house.
I was gonna be the best, most Christian kid.
And I was gonna be the best, most great kid for my dad,
you know, and do whatever he says, right?
And it just, but I had no say of my own,
like what I wanted was always fourth thing down the line,
you know what I mean?
And I was taught that like, literally,
like, it don't matter what you want, you know,
you better listen to what we're saying.
You better listen to what's going on here.
And so the neighborhood had pull, the gangs had pull,
my parents had pull, but I had no voice.
Right.
And you're just trying to keep the peace
and keep everyone else happy.
I mean, it's classic child of alcoholic stuff.
And what's, what's interesting about your story is like,
you've never, you've never drank, right?
Like you saw your dad, you're like, I don't want that.
You don't do drugs, but you know,
maybe you got the gene
and it just got expressed through porn.
Oh yeah. Right.
And it was that way.
I mean, alcohol would've served a similar purpose
of just numbing the pain.
Easy.
And allowing you to escape,
but then creating, you know, external circumstances
that weren't so good, which leads to that shame spiral.
But ultimately, because you're not dealing
with what's causing that internal pain,
you're always gonna go back to it.
That's right.
I mean, I shudder to think,
had I been involved with gambling.
I just go, oh my God.
Like, I would've been, I tell everyone,
if I had ever been like a drug dealer,
I would've been the worst.
(Rich laughs)
You know, I'd have been Nemo Brown.
I'd have been, (laughs) you know what I mean?
Like I'd have been Tony Montana and it would've been,
no, I just do everything to that level.
You know what I mean?
Like it's very extreme.
I didn't even go to a football play in school.
I ended up in the NFL.
You know what I mean?
It's just a very, very-
Just a whole crazy story
in and of itself.
Yeah.
I'm just, I have no,
what do I say, I go 100
and I have no half speed button.
You know what I'm saying?
It's kind of like, I'm either all in or I'm out,
and that's the way it's been, but it happens
like it works for me when it's a good thing.
And when it's a bad thing, oh my God.
Right.
It can tear up everything.
(gentle music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book,
"Voicing Change Volume II."
More than mere words on paper, "Voicing Change"
is a physical manifestation of the magic, inspiration,
and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the Rich Roll Podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was is a beautifully rendered book, worthy of display
on any coffee table, and "Volume II"
follows in that tradition by showcasing
even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication, replete with interview excerpts,
essays, and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained within.
"Voicing Change Volume II," available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
Well, I wanna put a pin in the whole pornography thing
and return to that, 'cause I want to talk
about the recovery piece there,
but as we're working our way through this story,
you make this pact with your friend Darwin.
You're gonna tell each other what you find out in the world.
Yeah.
But you do have,
like, there are a couple mentors who show up.
You have this teacher-
Yeah.
At Flint Academy who kind of changes your life.
He does.
First of all, there were two people.
One was a coach and one was a teacher.
My teacher was my art teacher named Mr. Eickleberg.
And he believed in me when I didn't believe even myself.
You have to understand like for me, especially in Michigan,
there are two Michigans.
There's like the white Michigan.
There's the Ann Arbor.
Yeah.
I'm from the white Michigan.
Yeah. You know what I mean?
There's Traverse City. It's gorgeous.
It's pretty there by the water.
And then there's Detroit and there's Benton Harbor.
There's Flint. There's Muskegon.
You know, I mean cities like that.
And what happens is I remember people talking
about the Cranbrook Academy of Arts, you know,
and there were no black people there,
you know?
Right.
I mean, not when I was a kid, it wasn't-
But Cranbrook is like the epic private school
in like, kind of near Gross Point, right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
And it's very white, very-
But has incredible arts program.
Oh, incredible. No, beyond belief.
But I said, (scoffs) I'm not going there.
Like that's not gonna be me.
I couldn't see a way in, right?
But I love to draw.
And I just was, I love doing my thing.
And Mr. Eickleberg looked at me
and he literally grabbed all my stuff.
He said, "Terry," he said,
"This is the best work I've ever seen."
He's like, "Hey man, I'm the teacher,
and you're better than me.
You could teach the class."
How old were you at the time?
Oh, I was, shoot, in 10th grade.
I was probably in 10th grade, 14 years old.
And he says, "Man,"
he said, "You have a tremendous talent."
And I was like, "Thanks, thanks."
And what I would do is back in the day, you know,
when the drug dealers took over, I mean,
the crack epidemic was hittin' hard.
It was like through the '80s
and then hip hop was coming along with it.
So what I would do is I would make all these sketches
of like Mickey Mouse as a drug dealer.
You know, this kind of stuff.
And they would print t-shirts.
And that was like, I would get $25 for a t-shirt.
My t-shirt would be all around the city
'cause everybody grabbed it and you see him,
he's have the cell phone and the, you know,
all the stuff and the accoutrements, the Fila shoes,
the Nikes, and you kind of ghettoize these characters.
And that was one thing that I did to make money
and kind of do that.
And I thought that's the pinnacle.
Like that's all the art's gonna be doing for me.
He took my art, photographed it,
basically put it all in to applications to all these places
and got me a scholarship to Interlochen Arts Academy,
which is one of the most prestigious arts academies
in the world.
Like Larry Page, the founder of Google went there,
amongst everybody.
I think Jewel went there too.
Oh, Jewel. I've been there, it's incredible.
It's life changing.
And he said, "Terry," he came up to me.
He said, "Terry," he said, "I want to give you,
I got something to tell you."
And I was like, "What do you mean?"
He says, "I got an announcement.
I got you the scholarship, one to Interlochen
and to Western Michigan University."
Because he had, by that time I was
around right before my senior year.
And he had got all that stuff for, you know.
He did it for you.
And did it,
and I didn't even know.
Wow.
And he was like, "That's how good I believe you are, man.
And you got it."
And I just shook, like what in the world?
And it changed my life.
Dude, to this day, it changed my, I remember when I go,
I went to Interlochen, out of about 500 people,
500 kids that were there for that summer session,
it was about six black kids, you know?
And so, and I was part of the arts department
and the arts program.
And so they had this curator
from the University of Cincinnati come and I had drawn,
they said and you have a big on competition.
So they were like, draw two drawings and put it
on the board, but don't put your name on it.
So I put it on the board and it was
amongst this whole wall full of everyone's drawings, right?
And they asked the curator which one was the best.
And he went all the way around the room
and he said that one,
and it was mine.
Mm.
And then he said, "So what's the next best?"
He went all the way around the room
and went to my other one.
And that's when it hit me.
The moment it hit me, and people were clapping
and they were like, "Well, that's Terry."
And I that's when I realized, wow, like,
I am, I'm as good as anybody.
'Cause I didn't believe it.
You know, I was told, but that was the moment
I was like, there is something here,
like this is special.
This is something that I can count on.
Like, this is, this is something
I have to invest in, you know?
And it changed my trajectory,
because again, I spent so much time hiding my art.
I spent so much time trying not to be a nerd.
You know, it was like trying not to be that guy,
'cause I would get super excited, but oh man,
I got these ideas, and they would look at me like,
all right.
Like who do you think you are?
And I was like, okay, let me just, all right,
don't worry about it, you know?
Yeah.
Even family-
Coming from like a, who do you think you are culture too.
Like, don't get so high on your own supply.
Totally.
I mean, you have to understand,
even my family members were like, who do you think you are.
Relax.
My father was straight up said, "Hey man,
the white man only gonna let you go so far."
That was his, you could put that on a t-shirt.
He would have that on as a mantra.
You might as well put that in a frame.
That was his lived experience.
That was it.
White man's only going to let you get so far,
so stop asking.
Like literally stop. And I just couldn't stop.
After I had that Interlochen experience
and I saw what I could do, I said, "I'm not gonna stop.
I'm not gonna stop asking."
So you end up at Western Michigan.
You get this scholarship, an art scholarship, to go there.
Yep.
The question then becomes like,
why didn't you just go full in on the art thing?
And instead you're like, I'm gonna play football.
Because it was only $500. (laughs)
Oh, okay.
Now understand.
You could go to college back in, what, in 1987,
you could go to college for $3,000.
You could. And you could work and go to college.
And for three grand, you would pay all your tuition,
do your whole thing.
Over the years, it turned into $100,000.
But back then you, the concept of you working
and going to college was pretty much normal.
Right.
So you still had to come up with 2,500 bucks.
You can't work and go to college.
Yeah, I paid $100,000 for my daughter's school.
I was like, where she gonna get a hundred grand from?
You know what I mean?
It's like, she can't do that.
So $500 went a long way,
but it wasn't enough to pay for everything.
And my mother went into, they went into debt.
My father was resisting the whole time.
Like, man, you need to do something else.
Go to vocational school, whatever.
I was like, look, I wanna go to college and the whole thing.
And she was like, look,
we only have enough money for one semester.
I think it was actually, she said, one year.
We'll pull together one year, that first $500
helped that first semester.
I can help with the other semester,
but after that...
And what happened is I didn't get a scholarship
that first year.
And I begged, I said, just gimme one more semester.
Now you have to understand, too,
my brother and sister were lacking,
and I asked for everything.
I literally was asking everybody
to contribute and it was selfish.
It was like, I can do this,
but I need everybody to contribute.
And it became with a level of resentment.
You know what I mean?
It was a little bit like,
hey man, why should we put all this into just you?
You know?
But I was like, I'm worth it.
I promise, I'll make it worth it.
And they did one more semester.
I got a scholarship.
And that was, let me tell you,
that's the one moment I found out and knew
that no was negotiable, you know?
Like as long as you just keep going,
eventually you're going to get what you want,
if you just don't stop.
Mm.
And that was a big, big moment for me
getting that scholarship.
It was incredible, but I still had a lot of,
and this is what's so scary,
and I write about it in a book is just,
I had a lot of entitlement, tons of entitlement
because this is another thing my mother viewed religion
like it was a magic wand.
You know what I mean?
It was you, you know, we name it and claim it, you know?
In Jesus name, I command my bills paid.
Mm-hmm.
But you do nothing.
Not a lot of action.
Nothing.
Just faith.
To get those bills paid.
Like you, I demand, in Jesus name,
I'm gonna lose 100 pounds, and die of obesity.
But they wouldn't, the lifestyle would never change.
Nothing would ever.
So, you know, Jesus became a fairy godmother
and I saw this and I was like, but why don't...
And I realized that I needed to combine,
I realized later, that I needed to combine
the talk with the action.
But up until that point, I was still a little bit of that
same like name it, claim it like, hey, Jesus got me this.
And so I was super entitled.
Like I didn't really want to work.
You know what I mean?
It was like everything,
it was out of my control, you know what I mean?
And I basically, you know,
was expecting a handout in a lot of ways.
And my whole attitude was just a mess, man.
Like to the point where I wouldn't work, you know,
after I got the scholarship, I felt like somebody owed me.
I had a lot of resentment to the school,
even while I was playing.
Mm.
Because I was like, you know, about time, you know?
And it was, it's weird how these little,
what you would call victories could actually
be the thing that keep you from true success.
You know what I mean?
Yeah. It's interesting.
I mean, from an outsider looking in,
it looks like you get this scholarship, it's not enough,
so you had the wherewithal to say,
I'm gonna walk onto the football team
and turn this into a scholarship
and then turn this into an NFL career.
That requires a lot of action, right?
Right. Right.
And a lot of self-belief.
Right.
But that doesn't get done unless you're committed,
because the odds are stacked against you.
Yep. Yep.
I have to say, even with the NFL,
this is another thing about the NFL,
which was really eye opening.
You know, you think it's discipline,
but it's not.
You know, someone's telling you
when to wake up or telling you
when to eat, telling you when to work out,
telling you when to practice and telling you
when to go to sleep.
This is why so many athletes have problems
when their career is over.
'Cause there's no one to tell you this stuff anymore.
It's not self-discipline.
It's the discipline that someone else
is telling you to get everything done,
but you're not going to succeed unless
you know how to do this yourself.
It's just not gonna happen.
Yeah.
And I was left without knowing any of that.
I mean, your story of transcending that into an even,
you know, bigger career is so the exception,
but you know, most guys, we think of NFL players,
they're ballers, they're making cash, they're living large.
Most guys have your experience,
which is every week they're vying for their job.
You're getting traded.
You're on five or six teams for maybe two years.
And then you call it a day and it's over.
And you're broke.
Yeah.
Most NFL players go broke probably within five years
of having their NFL career.
And how are you ever gonna recapture that,
you know, kind of excitement
about how you're living your life?
Nothing's gonna replace that.
You see, that's the mistake.
See, that's what's so crazy, I think is that,
can you imagine being 30 years old and the best thing
that was ever gonna happen to you has already happened?
Mm.
That's nothing but depression right ahead.
That's nothing but depression in the future.
There's no nothing to look forward to.
And then not only that, you fucked it up.
Mm-hmm.
And people do not hesitate.
And your whole life for 15 years before that
was all about getting to that place.
So there wasn't a lot of bandwidth for even thinking
about anything outside of that.
The fact that you had
this gift as an artist and something
that you were cultivating all along the way and using
as a means of survival is unique and unusual.
Yeah.
I would go back in the locker rooms once I got cut
and I would ask the star players
if they wanted their portraits painted.
(laughs) Yeah. Yeah.
And I would get like five grand a painting
and I would do three paintings and I would get 15 grand.
And that would get me through the off-season.
You know, we were poor, man.
But when told, let me, the biggest story, I tell
that was my super wake up call.
You know, my best friend to this day is a guy
named Ken Harvey who used to play with the Redskins
Right.
I was his backup.
And when I moved to LA, he helped us move to LA.
He gave us a loan and he actually,
I wouldn't even call it a loan.
It was a gift.
He was like, just go on out there.
I believe in your talent, he knew I was a good artist.
And he was like going out there and make your way.
And I didn't come out to LA to act.
I was actually trying to get behind the scenes.
I saw myself as a creator.
I mean, I was trying to do
that whole industrial light magic thing.
I was special effects artist.
I had my portfolio in that Disney, at Dreamworks-
Yeah, you show 'em the drug dealer Mickey Mouse?
Yeah. (laughs) Not that one.
Might get a cease and desist letter
for that one.
Yeah.
I definitely didn't show 'em that one,
but it was in the portfolio.
(laughs) Uh-huh.
Okay.
But what was crazy is that I thought, man,
this is gonna be my way.
I can actually draw my way into Hollywood.
And then "Toy Story" came out
and all hand-drawn animation was over.
Mm.
Overnight.
I remember submitting my artwork for "Prince of Egypt."
That was one of the last hand-drawn animation movies done,
and then when toy story hit, bam, it was over.
So, but I had this pride and entitlement still,
and I was going through depression
because football was over.
It didn't end the way I wanted it to end,
and you always have these lofty goals, and I was done.
We were in this really, you know, terrible duplex,
just trying to make ends meet.
I had no money. I was broke.
My wife, and this is the thing.
My wife, the whole time was like, you need a job.
Mm-hmm.
And I was like, come on.
You know, I'm pro football player.
It's gonna look crazy.
I'm not gonna be just doing anything, right?
And so I kept asking my friend for loans,
and Ken was giving me a loan and what was happening,
he would give me, he was a gold bug
and he would have all this gold bullion.
Some financial advisor had told him to put money in gold.
So it wouldn't, you know,
back then that was a big thing.
A lot of players were doing it.
Got like a stash of bars?
Yeah. It was coins.
(laughs) Uh-huh.
He would have these rolls of gold coins,
and they would be stashed around the house.
You know what I mean?
And that's the new...
Now, this cryptocurrency is the big deal,
but back then it was gold bullion.
And people were always, you know,
they were advising people to have some of your money
in gold and some of your money in this.
He would give me like a stack of coins and he would say,
Hey man, whatever the price of gold is that day, turn it in.
And each coin was like 300 bucks.
So he'd send me like five to six coins.
And that would get me through the month,
but come six, seven, eight months down,
I'm still asking for loans, right?
And we are going broke, man.
And I'm mean, when I say broke,
we were digging into couches for just money for milk.
And it was like, and my wife was like,
"Why don't you get a job, man?"
And I was like, "Yeah, but it's gonna work."
And 'cause I still had this fantasy
of something's gonna come save me.
Sure.
Like a Mr. Eickleberg
with a scholarship.
Right.
Or this and this or again, Jesus is gonna save us.
You know what I mean?
Don't you know
who I think I am?
And without me working at all,
I was using my mother's technique,
right?
Mm-hmm. Claim it.
And one day he said, "Man, no more loans."
Oh, okay. Okay.
Now, when your boys gets all high like that,
you know you're doing something wrong. (laughs)
I was like, "Oh, okay. Okay"
'Cause you know, you overstepped, you know?
Oh my God.
It was the first moment of like, he just pushed back,
and I hung up and I was like,
"I don't know who the fuck is he. Fuck him."
My whole attitude was like, he's supposed to be a friend.
And he's supposed to help me out.
And I'm saying, he knows I'm out here.
He knows I'm struggling.
What the hell, man? Fuck you.
And then this little voice came to me like,
Hey man, why are you mad at the only person
who helped you in the first place?
Yeah.
I went...
My family didn't give me any money.
Nobody else gave me.
He's the one who actually was giving me money.
I wasn't angry at anybody else who told me no.
I was only angry at the person who actually hooked me up.
Right, which is related to resenting Western Michigan
for giving you a scholarship.
You see what I mean?
It's that weird thing.
Same thing.
Imagine if you just gave $10 to some person every day
and all of a sudden you go, that's it.
They would go, "What the? Where's my 10 bucks?"
That's where I was at.
And I was like, I didn't deserve that.
I never earned it.
It was something that was a gift.
And he was like, no more.
And it hit me, man. I said, "I'm wrong, man."
But remember, remember my wife was telling me
this the whole time, but because I was a man
and because I viewed myself as more valuable than she was,
all her advice was secondary.
It was as if my kids were telling me something.
Yeah.
And 'cause I came at it as this attitude
of what masculinity is you you're supposed to already know.
So, you know, what your wife is saying
is mah-mah-mah-mah.
She was telling the truth the whole time.
But it's so crazy.
I would listen when Ken said it, it hit me.
Another man told me, I was like, oh damn.
And so the next day I got up like 4:30 in the morning,
went to this place called Labor Ready.
I mean, I'll never forget it.
It was in North Hollywood, five in the morning.
I show up with drug addicts, halfway house guys,
you know, straight out of prison,
trying to make it, whole thing, homeless.
And I show up and what they do at Labor Ready
is give you a job for the day
and you get paid at the end of the day.
And they sent me to this place called Whitecap.
And it was somewhere, I forget,
I think it was somewhere in the valley, right?
Some valley somewhere.
And I would go in there and hand me a broom.
And let me tell you some man,
I thought I was gonna pass out.
I said, if I start, like man,
I was in the NFL.
(Rich laughs)
Now I got this broom in my hand in a factory.
And I'm like, oh, oh.
I thought I was just going to fall to the ground.
All of a sudden I took that thing,
and I'm in tears, just welling up.
Like, this might be my life.
This might be where I'm at.
How did I fall so low?
How did I get from the NFL and all the promise
of the artwork and the neh-neh-neh and the scholarship,
and then I'm sweeping the damn floor in a factory.
But this is the craziness about it, and was so wow.
I started sweeping and all of a sudden I felt an energy
and I remember people were like, man,
"Hey man, you look a little familiar."
I was like, "Man, you don't know me."
And I pulled my hat down a little further
and I kept sweeping, but I got new energy
because I was actually for the first time
doing something about my situation.
Whereas before I was just sit and wait.
Yeah.
And I was like, oh my God.
And so I was like, let me get in the corners
and let me do, let me do this job.
'Cause another thing is the resisting work
is the hard part, but embracing work,
the day goes by like that.
And-
Well-
You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I got it.
I mean, it's interesting that you were able to like
do that math quickly.
Like generally takes a lot longer
before you kind of are lured into a place
of surrender to it, but that acceptance,
like I'm gonna be a worker among workers
is an act of humbling yourself.
But that's the place where you can begin to grow.
I mean, this is like a big, you know, you're sober now.
Like you understand like that piece, that acceptance,
and that humility is so important to growth, right?
Getting over your own, you know, self-aggrandizement,
idea of who you think you should be
and how people are supposed to interact with you
is a really beautiful thing, right?
And as you're telling that story,
I'm thinking about your dad polishing his shoes.
Like you have so little agency,
it's like the Serenity Prayer, right?
Yes.
Like there are so few things
that you have control over.
But you know what I have control over?
I have control over how I conduct myself
with this job today.
Yes.
And I can do it with a sense of gratitude
and pride.
That's right.
And that's gonna make it worth it.
Oh man.
There is a poem that I heard that I just love.
It says, and I can't pronounce the name
of the guy who wrote it.
I'll massacre it, but it goes, it says,
"I slept and dreamt of joy.
I awoke and realized
life was service.
I worked and then behold,
service was joy."
And that's whoa.
Whoa. That's it.
That's beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
And I went, that's what was happening.
And I did that eight hours.
I went back, got my check.
It was like $64.
They took out the taxes.
I had $48.
I put $20 in the gas tank.
I gave $20 to my wife for groceries
and I had $8 in my hand.
And I said, I will never be broke again,
because you know, you said it takes a while,
but it happened.
It kind of cracked that egg when I walked in there.
The fact that I actually got in the car that morning
and went in was you it's like, that's the egg cracking.
The sweeping was when it started to sizzle.
You know what I mean?
But I had, 'cause I would spend months not moving,
but that, I mean, I broke through that thing
'cause I thought everyone was gonna look at me
and everyone's gonna judge me and nobody cared.
No. 'Cause they're thinking about themselves. (laughs)
Exactly. No one is thinking about you.
You know what I mean? No one even knew me.
And that was this obstacle, this huge like wall
that I felt like I had to climb and I realized nobody gives
a damn about where I'm at.
Right.
So how long did you do that for?
Oh man, probably a a week.
A week.
And then, well, I went and applied for another
'cause once I broke that I went and applied
at another place called Western Staff Services.
And then I got a job being a,
I was filing all the papers that fell over
in the Northridge Earthquake
at the Veteran's Administration.
I was like this better than sweeping.
Right.
And so, but I was a filer.
And so I did that for a year.
But I didn't have to do the hard labor stuff.
But let me tell you something, man.
As I started to go and I started to,
I said, okay, we're here, this is my life now.
And I started to grow. I started to grow.
Now, mind you, there was still a lot of things
I didn't get right.
But I started to understand the entitlement piece.
It was like, you are not owed anything.
And I started to say, you have to work for this.
You know, this is not a, you gotta understand
that that religious mindset was actually
like a lottery mentality.
You know what I mean?
We just keep playing God, we keep rolling on God.
It's going to hit for us one day.
You know what I mean?
And you're left with nothing,
but I realized I can do some, like you said,
it was the Serenity Prayer,
the things that I can control, control it.
Mm-hmm.
You know what I mean?
But for a long, long time I felt
I couldn't even control what happened to me like myself.
I couldn't like if the wind went right, I was going right.
And the wind went that way, I would succumb to that,
and I realized I could walk straight.
I could really, really handle my own business and myself.
And then I started doing security for the movie sets.
And let me tell you something, I loved that gig.
It's wild when I look back, the first movie I ever did,
as security forward was a movie called
"Man on the Moon" with Jim Carey, Danny DeVito.
Yeah, sure.
Milos Forman was the director.
Yeah.
And I was standing in,
I'll never forget in my cast security shirt
and I would iron my shirts and put batteries
in my flashlight and I would work out and make sure
that I looked great.
And I was like, I'm in the movie business.
Right.
I'm in the movie business.
You know what I mean?
(Rich laughs)
It was so, and I was like,
I'm on a set, I'm on this whole thing.
And that was the really wonderful thing.
And I was happy, man. Like, I'll tell you this.
I'll never forget being like,
this is my life now.
I got settled to this is what it's going to be.
And I had no idea what was in store for me.
So you weren't casting your gaze on some goal
and like working in your free time to move forward on that?
Well-
You were just like,
this is where I'm at and this is what it's gonna be?
But let me tell you, I was working on my free time,
because what I would do is while I was standing there
doing that stuff,
I would write scripts or write down ideas.
I would go to the library because I couldn't afford
to buy the books.
I would buy books on Hollywood and when no one was around,
'cause sometimes they would have me watching areas
that they didn't want messed with.
So there was nobody.
So I would just read the books all day
and just stand there and read the books.
Yeah.
And just learn about the business
and learn about all this stuff, and-
But was it still about being an artist in the business
or was the idea of being an actor starting to creep in?
Artist.
Right.
Artists. Never an actor.
Never.
But you have had
that experience on set for "Training Day,"
right?
Right.
Which is pretty cool.
But listen,
this is even freakier.
I was security on a movie called "End of Days"
with Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Uh-huh.
Jeff Dawn, who is Arnold's makeup artist,
was walking on the set.
And he was, he came up to me, and I was a security guard.
And I was like, okay, extras, go this way.
You know, crews is over here.
He looked at me, he said, "Hey man, you ever act?"
And I went, "Aw, no, sir. That's not me."
He was like, "Dude, he said, you got a great look, man.
You need to, I'm serious. You really need to try it."
He said, "I'm a makeup artist. I do makeup.
And I'm Arnold's guy.
I'm here to tell you, you got a great look."
I thought he was hitting on me.
So I was like, (laughs) "Uh, thank you, sir.
Extras are this way and crew is that way.
Thank you very much."
Flash forward one year later, I'm an hired actor
on the movie "The Sixth Day" with Schwarzenegger.
I go into the makeup trailer. There's Jeff Dawn.
And he says, "Wait a minute, you look familiar."
I said, "You told me a year ago.
that I should be acting."
That's fucking crazy, yeah.
"And here I am."
And he said, "Holy shit!"
(Rich laughs)
Like he said, "I'm making people rich here." (laughs)
He said, "You're kidding."
You can't even make this up.
No, that's crazy.
You can't.
And you had the security gig that came
full circle too, right?
Right. Right.
It's, listen, man.
When I look at, you know, I remember just every opportunity.
It's kind of like you realize you,
if you wrote this stuff, it would be contrived.
You know what I mean?
It's truth is stranger fiction in every way.
And my thing is, you know,
from being a security guy and acting,
because we were broke and a friend of mine,
'cause I was bouncing, I had like two or three jobs.
I would do the security gig and I would bounce.
And a friend of mine was like,
"Hey man, there's this audition for this one show.
You should try it."
And I went home and I said, you know, so many,
I asked my wife, I said,
"So many people telling me I should try this acting thing."
She said, "Why not?"
Yeah.
She said, "Just go."
And I went and I got it.
First thing I ever auditioned for.
Is that the Battle Dome thing?
Battle Dome, which was American Gladiators on steroids.
Mm-hmm.
Okay?
And this is where all the football stuff,
everything played out.
And my first time as an actor,
and now I got the gig and I'm like,
I don't know anything about what acting is, right?
(Rich laughs)
So I did what-
Careful what you ask for.
Let me tell you what I did.
I did what I did when the kids would talk about "Star Wars"
and I would go home and start drawing it out
and think about what it is,
even though I hadn't seen the movie,
what I did was create a character,
and I said, okay, I don't know how to act,
but I know what I wanna see.
So what I'm gonna do is be what I want to see.
Mm-hmm.
How would I like to be seen?
Like if I was watching, what would I do?
And I became the breakout character.
I became this guy named T-Money
who was this bad guy from the hood and the whole thing,
and I was just vicious and mean,
and I would never let the contestants see me,
'cause it was a game show
where we fought.
Yeah.
They put me in a cage, set the ends on fire
and rotate the cage, and I would just wrestle
three contestants in a row, and it was bloody.
I mean we would leave bleeding every show.
This metal skin on metal. It was pre-MMA.
So there was no Ultimate Fighting.
No one knew anything about that,
but man, if you look at the clips,
it was one of the most brutal...
The log line for the show was "Real Competition, Real Pain."
Mm-hmm.
And that's all you need to know. (laughs)
And you're T-Pain. Yeah.
That's it, right?
And then, and man, we blasted people.
But what was happening is I was learning how,
it was like grand theater.
It was a lesson. It was a whole thing.
Like I was...
And let me tell you, I can't tell you the nerves.
They would put me behind a wall,
and every time the wall opened up and the warrior,
we come out and every time,
I felt like throwing up every time.
'Cause I said, I don't know what I'm doing,
and I wanted to run out of there.
But I was like, what am I gonna run to?
What am I gonna run to?
I'm gonna be back to security? Back to sweeping floors?
I said, hell no. And I had to go, I had to push.
It was the thing where
you've walked halfway across the country,
what are you gonna do?
Turn around?
Yeah.
You know what I mean? Like you gotta keep walking now.
Yeah. That imposter syndrome.
I mean, 'cause you don't have,
you still have never really done
any kind of formal training, right?
Mm-mm. Mm-mm.
And you have that story
of working on "The Expendables" where you have
that same experience where you have to kind of reckon
with yourself, like how am I gonna show up for this?
Yeah. Let me tell you about that.
What was wild is
because the sense of entitlement creeped back up.
I had already done a few movies,
done some things I end up in "The Expendables"
and I felt I wasn't getting used enough.
Like I'm thinking, I'm excited about being
an action star and I'm sitting in my hotel room,
and all of a sudden, Sly and everybody,
they're going on to set and doing.
Everyone else has done like 30 action movies, right?
And I haven't even.
The leading man for like their whole adult lives.
Dude.
(Rich laughs)
This is how insidious the attitude of entitlement can be.
It doesn't matter. It sneaks right in.
Someone gives you a little bit,
all of a sudden you're like,
why didn't I get the whole thing?
It's so pervasive.
But I was sitting in my hotel room and I was so mad
and I would go on and I was like, man,
instead of just being grateful, I said, you know,
I'm gonna say my line.
I'm gonna go home.
I got an attitude and it just crept in
and all of a sudden again, man,
it's that little voice.
Which is insanity,
given that you've been given this gift to be in this movie.
Insanity.
Yeah.
And it's the little voice, the same voice
that told me about Ken and like, why you mad at him.
It was like, hey man, you got this opportunity
of a lifetime.
What the fuck are you doing?
Like man, go in there and do your best every time.
Who cares?
And so what I did, it hit me.
I said, "Man, you're right."
Like all that alone time,
which I'm very thankful for, really helped
with the introspection.
Mm-hmm.
Because what happens is if you got
too many people around too many crew,
they can really talk you out of your dream.
They can really mess you up.
You like, yeah. You know what you should be.
Why are you not the start, you know?
And you get those wrong validating opinions and you're off.
And that crew will take you right out.
And I was alone.
And I went to work the next day
and I was thankful.
I said, man, just, I don't care what I'm feeling.
I said, I'm gonna give everything I got.
And I walked in. I said hello to everybody.
And I was like, what's the lines?
And I started to improv and do,
and Sly was like, "Man, hey man, I like you, man.
I'm gonna put you in over here today.
(Rich laughs)
You gonna save my life in this movie.
That's what he told me.
And I totally changed what happened in that movie.
That experience changed because of my attitude change.
Right, so he ends up rewriting the ending
to make you the hero.
It was, dude.
And I couldn't believe it.
And I realized that was so like, that was another lesson.
Same lesson when I got my scholarship.
It was that lesson that like, wait a minute, man.
You know this, you can change this thing.
You can, your attitude can never, ever waiver.
You have to have,
you can't let entitlement creep in
and steal what's yours.
Yeah.
Gratitude being the antidote to in entitlement.
Exactly. Exactly.
So how does, I mean, you've spoken a lot about gratitude,
how you're the most grateful person,
but gratitude is a practice.
It didn't come to you easily early.
So how do you make sure that you're on top
of your gratitude?
Well, you know, I basically, you know,
you look at your results, you look at where you are,
you look at what's happening, you know what I mean?
And one thing is I always can, this is one thing,
even like writing a book, journaling,
I used to write my top 10 goals down every day.
And I did that for probably 15 years.
So, and I had, you know, the Franklin planner.
You remember those?
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
I have tons of those stacked up.
And what helps me with gratitude.
I go back to 2001, my Franklin planner and look
at those top 10 goals and I did 'em all.
Like way exceeded them.
Like, and then I go back to 2005 and I go, oh, all that.
And then I go into 2008, I did all that.
And it's so it fills me with the gratitude
that I'm supposed to have.
'Cause you know where you were
and what was so amazing at that time.
Like if I could only make a million dollars a year,
you know what I mean?
And you go, wow, wow. I've gone way past. (laughs)
You're like, holy God.
Right.
It's a weird thing.
Like I'm really interested in this.
So, you know, in my own case, like it's wild
that I'm sitting across from you
and that I get to do this thing,
and it's not anything that ever found its way
into my version of the Franklin planner.
It's this tension between yes, you wanna set goals
for yourself and you wanna work hard
and show up and be diligent.
But also you have to make space for the miracle,
because you can't imagine what your life
could possibly be, right?
Like you have to, you have to hold
that tension with the goals that you're seeking
a little bit loosely.
Yes.
So you can make space for stuff
that you can't even predict for yourself.
And for me, it always goes back to the inside job.
Like how much am I working on myself?
Where are my blind spots?
Where are the things that, you know,
I could be more grateful or, you know,
work on some other area.
And it seems completely disconnected from whatever goal
I'm seeking in the external world.
But all I know is that when I'm doing that,
when I'm engaged in that process,
that's where I'm sort of taking that insurance policy
out on greater possibility that I can't quite fathom.
Exactly.
And you know, and I had to find these challenges.
Like there's a thing.
'Cause you get complacent,
and it's the comfort zone.
And there was a time as an actor, you're like,
you're gonna get hired it.
It's all good.
And you're gonna be on a sitcom or some sort show,
you'll be the fourth lead.
And you'll be like, and you can just live that life.
Like, you know, you'll be that guy on the CSI or whatever.
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine" for the next 20 years.
And you did it for eight.
Or another version of that.
But yeah, so.
You can just do.
But then this is the thing.
I was like, there's more and I felt too comfortable,
and it made me weird because I was going,
I don't like complacency because I'm a little,
I started to study it and start to look at it.
And it was like, man, you getting a little,
like, it's almost like getting chubby.
(laughs) You know what I mean?
Where you're like, I'm just eating the same things
and I'm not really, I said, I need a challenge.
I need something that's gonna excite me.
So I started, I forced myself into hosting.
Forced myself.
Mm-hmm.
Like you gotta understand, 240-pound muscular,
big guy was not the first guy
you would think of as a television host.
Yeah, but you got the charm and the charisma.
But again-
And the smile and the teeth
and the whole thing.
Well, now.
Yeah. (laughs)
At the time,
people were like, does he?
Mm.
I know him from "Everybody Hates Chris."
I know him from, you know, this kind of thing.
And so I remember going in and doing an audition
for "Who Wants to Be a Millionaire,"
the daily version of that.
And let me tell you, I could tell you that,
it was actually a failure, okay?
That was not a good look because here I was
on a game show,
the daily version of a show that had been on TV for years.
And I'm this character who talked way too loud
for the daytime audience.
Hey, how you guys doing today? Yeah!
So I overcompensated, and it was a little much
for that audience 'cause they, you know,
the people were like, "Well I'm drinking my tea
and he's screaming at me.
Stop screaming."
All the notes were like "stop screaming," you know?
Uh-huh.
And here I was and I would do this daily thing.
I did 360 episodes in a year
of "Who Wants to Be a Millionaire"
while I was doing "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
Ah, you were doing it
at the same time, wow.
So I would fly
to the east coast, do the show, and then do like,
we would do almost seven episodes in a day.
Like, bap-bap-bap-bap-bap-bap all day.
I was exhausted, then fly back
and go right to "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
But I said, I have to get this.
Like it was hook or cook. I said, I'm going to learn this.
And it gave me an opportunity to do it.
And let me tell you, it didn't go well,
because they fired me the first year.
I mean, when the year was over,
they were like we're gonna, they went with Chris Harrison.
I had to understand.
I was like, "Oh man, it just didn't work."
So there I was, I said, I gave, I put my heart.
I had actors that are like, "Why are you doing this?"
They would come up to me and they would say,
"Terry like, man, you could be doing this acting.
Why don't you do some more movies?
And why don't you do this?"
I said, because what I saw was the future.
I saw, I got tired of waiting to be picked.
Mm-hmm.
And I said, if I learn this skill,
then I don't have to be picked.
I could choose. I can choose.
You know, there's not a lot of people.
Like when you look at big super stars or people,
just charm doesn't mean you could host.
It doesn't mean you could do
all that stuff.
Yeah.
'Cause it's a whole nother thing.
I said, I have to learn this.
And man, what was so wild,
and to this day, this is when you,
this is to your point about leaving room.
I'm hosting the number one talent show in the world.
Yeah.
The fourth year.
And I look at this, like this was never on the list.
I didn't know it would go this far.
I was just trying to secure a future,
hopefully do some things.
And you know, that would allow me to pivot
in different ways, but never did I see this.
Yeah it's crazy.
It's crazy.
It's crazy. It's crazy.
It's the biggest show in the world.
And I gotta tell you, I think, you know,
I will admit to being somewhat dismissive
of the whole host thing, like, ah, come on.
That's not like real acting.
That's not, you know, they're reading off the prompter
and the whole thing, but I just had to host
an all-day conference in Miami,
I do a fair amount of speaking.
(Terry laughs)
I was like, how hard could it be, you know?
And I go there and I'm like, holy shit.
Like I'm responsible for holding the energy
for this group of, you know,
this huge auditorium of people
for like an eight hour stretch.
Like I better get my shit together.
Yep.
Ended up like rehearsing for eight hours,
wrote a 35-page script and, you know,
had to go out in between each speaker and come up
with jokes on the fly
and figure out.
Yes.
And I ended up leaving that experience,
A, with just a huge amount of respect for how difficult
that job is and how specific that skillset is
and how different it is from typical public speaking,
and also any other kind of like performance-oriented thing
that I'd ever done,
but also it's completely thrilling.
Like it's so gratifying.
Like 'cause you are like,
you have to have these people in your hands,
you know?
That's right.
And if, when you're in your kind of flow
and you know that you're firing on all cylinders,
it's a pretty cool thing.
Let me tell you, you know what I like to call it,
they give me the keys to NBC.
Yeah.
I get the keys.
I mean, it's the biggest-
You have it.
It's the biggest show in the world.
Wait, and it goes ding ding ding
and you have NBC in your hand, there's only you.
And everyone's looking at you
and it's like those doors open, you walk out,
and you are representing everything.
You're representing 30 Rock.
You're representing Simon Cowell,
you're representing every act.
You're representing what the show means.
It's been on for 17 years,
and you have it in your hands.
And it's like, Aw! And it reminded me of the NFL.
You know what I mean? It was that thrilling.
Like the ball could go anywhere, boo.
Oh, and it's live by the way. Live.
So anything can happen.
Right.
You know, I'll never forget, the prompter goes out.
It happens.
You still have to keep the show going
and you have to explain the rules and other,
because there's rules.
There's things that people want to try to win money.
You can't miss, you misinterpret it, people get sued.
It's crazy. It's that pressure.
And then the prompter goes out
and you still have to know what you're talking about,
and it's like, oh my God.
And dude, I go home. I'm exhausted.
Every fiber am I being is exhausted.
And I'm happy, like I just played in the Super Bowl.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, 'Cause you're the glue.
I mean the panelists have to weigh in on the acts.
Exactly.
But they're not responsible for keeping the show moving.
Not at all.
Yeah.
I go to them for an answer.
I give them a question, but then I'm responsible
for bringing the act out, introducing these guys,
explaining the rules to the public.
I am, and it's so thrilling.
I can't, like you said, do it,
and then you think it's full,
the place is full of, you know,
probably 6,000 people in the (indistinct).
Mm-hmm.
And then you turn around and say, no,
it's really a hundred million people watching.
That kind of thing.
Yeah that's a mind fuck.
Holy yeah. (laughs)
We had Oz Pearlman in here the other day,
you remember him, the Mentalist.
Yes. Whoops.
(ice clatters)
Look at me, I'm sorry. I'm making' all this noise.
I think he ended up third maybe five years ago
or something like that.
Do you remember that guy?
Yes. Yes.
He was the Mentalist.
Yes. The Mentalist, yes.
I remember him.
He's pretty cool.
He was screwing with our heads.
Dude, we get some great-
I know.
It's unbelievable the quality of talent
and all the stuff that you get to see.
But I'm gonna tell you this and let me tell you,
every act that comes through reminds me of me.
It reminds me of being in Flint, Michigan,
dreaming of being some and somehow involved
in entertainment, you know, no matter what it is
and everybody had you huge, huge obstacles
to get to that point.
Mm-hmm.
Huge.
And a lot of people say, well, you know, yeah,
who hates the sob story and the whole thing,
but there's not an entertainer that doesn't,
'cause it's all rejection.
Yeah.
All of it.
You just have to find ways to deal with your rejection.
And so I look at these acts and I'm their a bodyguard.
I'm their protector.
I'm the person that gives them
what they need on the way out,
and then I'm the person that counsels them
when they come back out from the audience,
you know what I mean?
And it's like, if it doesn't go well,
I let them know that this is just the beginning.
Mm.
And if it goes great,
I let them know you gotta come back next week with more.
You know, it's just, and it reminds me of me.
And also I try to the people that are successful,
I really, really try to pull something
and learn something from them.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And it's just a beautiful relation.
I learn a lot doing that show, man.
That's cool.
'Cause you meet
so many different people and it's one of the highlights
of my life, but it really, really was
one of those things that I had to get
out of my comfort zone.
I had to find something new and I'll be honest with you,
I don't know what's next.
I've been designing furniture.
Right.
And my wife is like, "Why are you doing this?"
I'm like, I don't know.
I need a challenge.
You gotta feed
the artist though, right?
You have to.
Are you painting still?
I'm painting, I'm drawing, I'm sketching.
Still designing I'm in the fourth iteration
of my collection with Bernhardt,
but there's something else coming.
Like right now I've been challenging myself to do, you know,
more dramatic things.
You know, I did a stint on a show called
"Tales of the Walking Dead," which is not funny at all.
I love that challenge.
I see myself doing, but this is another thing, man,
writing these books and being so vulnerable and putting
my story out there is like moving from fiction
to nonfiction, is what I like to say.
It's literally the next step,
what I feel in my career is it is beyond being an actor,
but being a person of interests, you know?
Where let's talk about things together, being, you know,
'cause this is another thing like being a host,
it's almost like being able to have conversations
with people and learn from people and tell your story
is the only way we're gonna get by problems.
This is why you and I are sitting here right now.
It's because this is nuance.
And what we are witnessing right now is the death of nuance.
Mm-hmm.
No one is talking.
Everyone is screaming at each other.
Just look at any daytime talk show.
It's all yelling at each other.
And at the end of the day, it's like, you know,
we showed you, pow, you know, mic drop.
Yeah.
And we'll see you tomorrow.
And I'm going...
It gets the hits.
It charges the dopamine,
but ultimately everybody as a human being
has that deep desire for connection and for nuance.
And I think that's a big reason why, you know, podcasts
have grown in popularity.
People would tell me all the time,
like you gotta make these things 30 minutes.
Like who's gonna listen to you guys banter on forever?
But you know, it's been quite the opposite,
because I think people are starving for it.
Starving.
Honestly, it is, you know,
our version of the campfire and we need that campfire
if we wanna solve our problems and the solution
to our problems lies in appreciation of nuance.
And you can only get to the nuance when you take the time
to sit down and calmly, you know, talk through stuff
that I think is important.
(upbeat percussive music)
(logo whooshing)
You know, and we haven't even gotten to like the main thing
that I want to talk to you about, which is like, D-Day.
Yeah.
You know, you being this really successful person
who on, you know, from an exterior view,
had it all going on.
Inside, you're a very different person.
Ultimately you have this bottom, this reckoning
that becomes a catalyst for all the growth
and the expansion that you're able to kind of exude
and speak to now.
Look, you know, this is so crazy
and it hit me so hard.
You know, that there I was,
I was extremely successful.
I mean, living the life, living the dream.
Like I said, going through my Franklin planner and realizing
that I hit every last one of my goals,
and I was miserable.
And my family was miserable.
Mm-hmm.
And no one liked me.
And I said that that can't be it.
There has to be another level of success.
And what I discovered is that I, you know, I wasn't real.
I had created an image.
I had created Terry Crews, you know,
with a restricted, you know, TM, trademark,
(laughs) you know what I mean?
It was like, it wasn't real.
But everybody loved it. Everybody loved it.
It was so good. It was so pure and amazing.
Everybody loves Terry Crews oh, but my wife knew.
I knew, because this, the problem is
I never told my wife about my pornography addiction.
And back in 2010, we had a day called D-Day,
and it was wild because that's the day I confess
to basically going to a massage parlor,
getting a hand job and cheating on my wife 10 years earlier,
which was back in 2000.
But I vowed when that happened.
I mean, it was probably the darkest day of my life,
'cause that's where my addiction had brought me.
And I was just like, man, I never thought again, what.
It's just like those good goals that happened.
You're like, I never thought I'd be here.
But those bad habits brought me to
I never thought I would be here.
And it was the hardest.
I just vowed I would never tell anybody.
I vowed that's my secret to take to the grave.
I'll never say it.
Yeah, the big fear being, if you actually told
your wife who you were, that she would leave.
And this is then let me tell you the biggest trick
about that and the biggest lie.
And the thing is that what we are really searching
for is intimacy, as men.
I don't, I don't, again, I'm not gonna speak for women,
but I know for me, intimacy is what I need.
But the problem is if you never tell who you really are,
you can never find true intimacy.
And this is where you could be as a guy going
from sexual experience, just sex, sex, sex, sex,
and never finding anything
that's meaningful because you're not revealing
who you are.
You know what I mean?
And it's like, I had this image that my had married
and what she thought was her life, but it was really not.
And but she was always suspicious.
So she would always ask me,
and I remember because of my guilt,
I would start an argument just to get out of conversations.
Distractions.
Right. Be, oh look!
And suspicions is bred from lack of trust.
And that kind of running, and oh my God, look at that.
And now I'm out of here.
And there was a wall and every time
I use pornography, it created a wall between us.
Now this is the thing.
And you know, it's different if two couples are into it
and they want to do that, the whole thing,
well then there's your transparency right there.
But to be hiding something is a whole nother matter.
And the way I like to phrase it, sometimes,
'cause guys, a lot of times don't understand it.
They feel like man, we're guys though.
You know, we enjoy looking at women, you know,
what can it be?
What kind of problem?
But the thing I like to say is imagine
if your wife was taking money from another guy
and didn't tell you.
What? Immediately guys go, "What are you talking about?"
Just imagine, if some guy was giving your wife money,
there's $1,000 or $2,000
and you find out for three years
she's been taking money from another guy.
Well, we didn't have sex, we didn't do anything.
But you know I'm a woman. I need money. (laughs)
Guys would be like, hell no.
No, not if you're gonna be,
you know, you consider yourself my wife,
or no, we're not gonna do that.
In fact, that's unacceptable.
In fact, what are you doing?
And the flip side is exactly how your wife feels.
It's like, why are you getting that from someone else?
I was supposed to be that.
That's what least was my wife's attitude.
And just to help people kind of frame the picture,
I had had this thing where I was more valuable
than the women in my life, simply because I was a man.
First of all, sports culture told me that,
black culture told me that,
male culture told me that,
everything in my life said, it's your way or the highway.
Hey man, I didn't love my family.
I owned my family,
and you're supposed to do what I say.
I wasn't really listening to you.
It was blah, blah, blah.
But a true equal can come to you and you have
to respect what they say.
A true equal can challenge you on your beliefs
and on your moves and say,
mm, I got a problem with that, Terry,
but I wouldn't even allow that
because you're not an equal to me.
So what was the reckoning? How did that change?
Well, first of all, she left.
When I told her, first, 'cause this is the thing,
D-Day went like this, "What is it
I don't know about you, Terry Crews?"
Is what she asked me because,
and I was on the phone with her for like two hours.
Just like mah-mah-mah-mah-mah-mah.
But she's like, "There's something you're doing.
I don't know."
It was again, you see that woman getting some money.
You're like, where'd you get that.
Sometimes, you know, two and two equals four.
It's not adding up. Something's up.
And I just, I was tired.
I was tired of lying.
I was tired of being done.
I was, I was actually done with the relationship.
I was done with the marriage.
It was one of them things like,
why even keep putting up with this?
Because first of all, Hollywood didn't care
If I lose my family.
I'd get more movies. They'd be like, hey man, good.
You got no wife to come home to.
You can do three more projects.
And she's the only one challenging you.
Only one. Only one.
'Cause Hollywood doesn't care. Porn, shoot.
No big deal.
It's like, in fact, we'll get you some girls.
And I literally was done with my marriage.
'Cause I was feeling like, again, back to entitlement,
but also not appreciating, no gratitude
for what she's done, but I had moved into this
I'm Terry Crews, though.
'Cause that's the image.
And I got, I told her and she just, I can't.
Like to me, I was like, well, it happened 10 years ago.
And to be honest, I was a little bit like,
where you gonna go?
Like I'm Terry, you know, I got all this.
I'm doing good.
Oh man, the attitude was horrendous. It was horrendous.
And I, and she was just like, "I can't believe..."
Like to her, it happened the same day.
But to me I'm like,
"It was 10 years earlier," nah-nah-nah-nah.
And she said, "I'm done."
She said, "Don't come home. Don't."
And I said, "Okay, I won't. Fine."
I said, "Go."
I said, "You know, I can just go
find another woman like that."
So, you know, whatever you want to do, you can do.
And she was like.
I hung up. And my marriage was over.
And then that same damn voice, that little voice,
the one that talked to me way back in the day
about Ken Harvey, the little voice that was talking
to me all this time, it said, man, what if it's not her?
What if it's you?
I was like, no, it can't be me. Can't be me.
Look, first of all, I'm doing everything I'm supposed to do.
I'm successful. I'm successful.
I have done this, this and this.
And the fact that look at where I came from.
I'm a black man. I was poor.
I made it all the way up here. I did all these things.
In fact, I got a high sex drive, you know what I mean?
So, you know what I mean?
I got a little more testosterone than the average man.
I mean, I had... (laughs)
(Rich laughs)
You know, I had totally made
that thing up, and I was all in the image.
And all of a sudden it said
but it's you though.
And the question I used to frame,
I would frame the question about all this stuff,
I would ask my, you know, like I would think
about my wife and I'd be like, why didn't she believe me?
And in an instant, that question changed to why am I lying?
Same context, but one was blaming her,
and the other one was like, this is me.
I'm lying. I've been lying the whole time.
You did lie.
Like, you could say you weren't,
but you were lying the whole time.
And then I knew, I said, man, I'm in trouble.
Like I started to have a crisis.
And when I say that, it was like,
I didn't care about Hollywood anymore.
I didn't care about, like first it's like,
I'll keep moving and I would just do more on movies.
But he like, but I don't care about doing movies.
It was a crisis.
When I say a crisis, it was like,
I don't care about anything.
I'm done. Like, I'm a farce.
Yeah, it feels like porn opened up the door,
but what it really was, was like an existential reckoning
with the fact that you've been living
some version of a double life-
Yeah.
For a very long time, until it just became so
unsustainable and exhausting that you had to confront it.
First of all, that's the way all these things work.
All these vices, you know, some people make so much money,
they can gamble until they can't,
until they're taking a house.
Some, they drink all day until you get,
your liver can't take anymore.
Yeah, it works until it's not working anymore.
Until it's not working.
Yeah.
That's what my friend, Steven Tyler said,
he said, "All addictions work until they stop working."
Sure. Yeah.
Uh-oh.
And then they don't work for a while
(Terry laughs)
until they reach your pain tolerance,
and you're probably a guy you can deal with of pain, right?
So as the elevator's going down, the excuses start
to stack up until it just becomes so unmanageable
that you have to like throw your hands up and give up.
With, you know, the thing about the excuses thing, man.
And I learned, it's funny, 'cause excuses are valid
for a minute,
but then it's like an expired credit card, man.
You runnin' around and you keep trying
to plunk that thing down and you get declined.
(Rich laughs)
You know what I mean?
It's kinda like every excuse does not work.
And well listen, when I got declined by my wife,
I put the credit card down like, hey, here you go.
And it's like, no, that's expired, man.
But responsibility gives you a whole new credit limit.
Like the minute you start taking responsibility,
you start to build that credit back up,
you start doing all this stuff.
So I went and I went to counseling and now this is
another thing is in black culture where I grew up,
you did not get therapy.
It was seen as you can't cure crazy.
Mm.
If you crazy, can't cure it.
You know, every family had uncle that they would lock
in the basement or there somebody upstairs
who just wasn't all together and you just-
You just go to church and pray about it.
That's it. You pray about it.
And you just, you got a demon. That was what they would say.
So-and-so's got a demon, and that was it.
But there was no cure.
And if you get that mumbo-jumbo in you,
all of a sudden, you're gonna be more confused.
And how I learned this is that what was so crazy
is my father went to a psychologist to deal
with his alcoholism and the psychologist killed himself.
I was a teenager. And I was like, that's it.
Wow. Yeah.
You're right.
He jumped off a bridge.
And I went, yeah, they're all crazy.
And I said, and so I had this,
I was an this thing, like I'm not gonna get near that.
But that was the moment when I said, I went to my,
I called my friend in the middle of D-Day.
And he said, man, he said,
"I can't tell you're gonna get your wife back,
but you need to get better for you."
Now, it was a strange concept.
I gotta explain this, because everything I did
was to get something.
Like every bit of work, every bit,
I was doing good so that I can get money,
or working hard so I can get this.
Working to...
But there was never a realization of just doing something
for your own sake.
Just being good to be good,
just to be better.
'Cause again, that's internal,
that's something, it was always external rewards.
But he said, "You need to get better for you."
And I was like, "What?"
You know, I would do whatever to get sex
or do whatever to get money.
But even the working out,
even all of that was so you could front or show up
and look a certain way.
Yes. Yes.
And it was again, you worked out
so you could show people, I'm not gonna be messed with.
You know, that kind of thing.
Or that was back when I was young,
and then you show out to show how great you are.
You know what I mean?
But just to do it for me anyway?
And I went to rehab.
Yeah.
First day in rehab, I was like, oh, dude,
I'm in the wrong place.
This is not me.
Where did you go?
Did you go to like Meadows or someplace?
No, I went to a place called
Psychological Counseling Services in Phoenix,
Phoenix, Arizona.
And I'm sitting in that room with about 10 other people
and they're all talking their issues and I'm going
and the whole thing, it was a little bit like
this was the same thing
like going their Labor Ready where I was like
everybody's gonna care.
Everybody, but everybody had their own damn issues
that they had to deal with.
And so, and I was thinking, everybody's gonna know
it's me and everybody, but I said damn it,
I gotta go.
And listen, and I did not go to get my wife back.
My whole thing, I really knew my marriage was over.
I just said, well, I'm just gonna have to try
to get myself together.
And when I did, and after the first day I was like,
this is not me.
And then all of a sudden they were like,
"Hey man, was your dad an alcoholic?"
I was like, "Yeah."
And "So was your mom very religious?"
I was like, "Oh, how'd you know that?"
(laughs) Yeah.
And wait, and they started reading my mail.
Like it was all these things that started to come down.
And I was like, Oh my God, that is me.
This is me.
And it just, dude, it changed everything.
Like I went on this journey
and I'm still on it for 12 straight years.
I probably like, I, every time I'm in the gym,
I have an audiobook going about cognitive therapy,
about thinking about thinking,
about reexamining all the things you know,
there's one book that I love.
It's like, "You Are Not So Smart."
It's a book that totally revamps the way you think
things are and they're not.
And then there's another book that followed it
called "You Are Now Less Dumb." (laughs)
(laughs) That's the graduate.
Yeah, yeah. It was so good.
And so I started to think my way through life,
instead of 'cause remember now women, this is one reason
I think women can tend to be a lot smarter than guys
because they don't push their way through things.
They have to think their way through life.
You know what I mean?
So they're a lot more intuitive, whereas,
hey man, with within male culture,
if you got the biggest bench press, you run the business.
You don't know anything about inventory.
You don't know anything about that.
But if you're the strongest guy,
everybody treats you like, this is where,
if you're super tall, you're a basketball player.
You are the king of the world.
Right.
And that's the way those operations,
that's the way we operate.
And I had to start thinking for the first time,
for real about who I want to be,
where I'm at and what was happening in that whole course,
I had to raise my life like totally dump truck it, man.
Like I started all over from the beginning,
and I went on a 90-day sex fast.
Yeah.
Like, and I'll never forget,
'cause we went 75 days the first year,
and my wife was willing to, you know,
come back in and I would think she's like, well,
we don't have, I'll let you back in
and the whole thing and we'll be good.
But the next year, it always got me.
I said, we went to 75. I said, "We gotta do it again."
So the next year I went on another fast
and I made it the whole 90 days,
because I said it was so important to me,
because this was the thing, man.
Remember I had let my body
and these things overcome
what I wanted to do.
So if I wanted sex, I would get it.
If I wanted to eat, I would do it.
If I dah-nah-nah...
'Cause I was like, I have no control.
But I said, I have to control these things.
Like, and if that means fasting these things,
and so I haven't ate breakfast for 12 years.
Mm-hmm.
I have been intermittent fasting.
Right.
Since that period.
We're gonna get into that,
but like, yeah, that practice of, I mean, it's really,
it's powerful and empowering because it puts you
into contact with the truth of the behavior.
Like it's not until you stop doing it,
that you realize, that you start to understand
the reasons why you were doing it,
like that you were doing it to check out emotionally
or to act out, or to serve some kind of,
you know, internal, fucked up need that you have,
because when you're in the process of doing it,
it's so normalized, right?
Right.
Like I know I went to treatment in back in '98,
and it was suggested to me that I take a year celibate
after leaving treatment because my relationship
with the opposite sex was so convoluted with my alcoholism.
Yeah.
And I couldn't,
it was because I was so insecure
around the opposite sex or I, you know,
I would rely, everything was like a mess.
And the only way to get clear was to put that distance
between those two things for an extended period of time.
And it was so empowering.
And I could, I really, because then it's just you and you.
Yeah.
And you gotta deal with that shit.
Yeah, yeah. Yes.
Right?
And there's no escape from it, and I learned a ton.
And then when the year ended, I met my wife,
and that was that, so. (laughs)
That's sweet. Hey, man.
You know?
Well, you know, that's how I felt.
I felt like I met my wife after that.
That was so crazy.
We've been married for 20 years at that point.
And going through that, I felt like I met my wife,
which is nuts.
That's funny you would say that because you know,
there was a time in our lives, man, when we were 12,
and you have a crush on a girl, whatever,
and you pull a flower out, you weren't thinking about sex.
You don't even, I didn't even know what it was.
I just was like, all I could think about is like,
I appreciate this girl.
I appreciate who she is just for,
she's beautiful because she's just her.
And it was beyond what her body looked like, and eh.
It was just like, there's a feeling of care.
Like I care for you.
I wanna see you win. I want to see you succeed.
And it had nothing to do with sex.
And that's exactly what I felt for my wife
with those 90 days.
It became our conversation, started to talk about...
It wasn't about what was gonna happen
at the end of the combo.
You know what I mean?
'Cause it's funny how over the years with porn
and different things, it was like,
all right, well, you know what means.
We had a good combo. Now you gotta do something for me.
Hmm.
It was the tit for tat.
Yeah.
But when you have a real conversation
with no expectations, all this getting,
but it was all giving.
Dude, it was a whole nother level and it allowed
our relationship to be rebuilt.
And beyond that, you start to reckon with your anger
and with all of these other, you know,
we started this conversation
talking about unhealthy masculinity.
It really helped you unpack all these other aspects
of your life and, you know, traumas that you experienced
as a young person to, you know, get whole with all of that.
I mean, that's really the broader message
than just, again, it's like the porn
that brings you in the door.
Yeah.
But ultimately, the gift was so much more expansive.
Again, the phrase I use is cracking that egg.
You can't, it's starts to spill,
or you hit that first domino,
you know, and the dominoes just keep going.
You know, it was like, oh my God.
'Cause I had big anger issues.
The road gets narrower.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, and I mean, I was very violent, man.
I mean, there's a long list of people
who Terry Crews has knocked out, okay?
Which was crazy.
I start the book out talking about a time in Pasadena.
We were headed to the "The Longest Yard" wrap party,
and this guy, I felt, disrespected my wife
while we were waiting for a car.
And man, I put him on his head on the concrete, dude.
Like it was overkill, you know,
in every sense of the word, you know what I mean?
It was like, whoa.
And the police came and it's a crowded,
you know, bunch of people.
It was Christmas, people were Christmas shoppin'.
It was packed in downtown Pasadena.
And man, thank God, thank God.
This man, this older white man
came out of the crowd and said, I saw this whole thing,
and they were just waiting for their car
and they were bothered by this gentleman.
So, but the police came with their hands
on their guns, ready to arrest somebody.
And my wife was shook.
She was like, "Terry."
And we went home after all that.
And she said, "You have to promise me
you'll never do that again.
You have to promise."
She said, "I'll be okay, but you have to promise me."
And I was like, "What are you talking about?"
I said, "I'm a man. Like, this is what men do."
I said, "First of all, I can't make that kind of promise,
because when somebody needs their ass whooped,
I'm going be there to deliver it."
'Cause I had no problem with that.
You know what I mean?
I mean, but dude, she was like, "Terry,
like at the minimum, we could get sued and lose everything.
And at the maximum the police could shoot you."
You're going to jail.
And kill you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah exactly.
(Terry laughs)
Like it's a couple things.
I mean, first of all, this is how the book opens.
So you open with a pow,
and short of the white guy telling the white cops
that they should be going after the other black guy,
not you the black guy.
I mean, that's a whole conversation right there, right?
Yes.
But also it's impossible to read the first few pages
of your book and not think about the whole Will Smith thing.
Exactly.
I mean,
the parallel between that episode
and what the world just witnessed, you know,
is pretty spot on there.
Listen, man, it was so crazy.
I got calls out of the blue from everybody
who was involved with me writing the book.
They were like, it's like you wrote this,
like you knew it was gonna happen.
I was like, man, I was Will Smith.
That's all I can say.
Talking about empathy.
I mean, first of all,
I did way more worse than what Will's done, (scoffs) okay?
You just didn't do it
in front of a hundred million people.
Right, it just wasn't on camera.
But when you look, listen, you know what?
Because the thing in the incident that you share
in the book, what really tipped it over
is when the aggression was directed
at your wife, not at you.
That's right.
That's what really set you off.
Totally. I mean, and I was like, "You're gonna die today."
Like I said, it was overkill.
It was to the point of like, I could have killed this guy.
I mean, when you put somebody on their head on the concrete,
a lot of things could happen.
Yeah.
And it wasn't, she just was shocked
at the level of violence.
So then what is the message with Will Smith?
Or like what do you take from that?
Or what is it that you wanna say about how that went down?
First of all, I'm gonna tell you this.
And this is, this is the overall message for me
is that there was many, many times I was Will Smith.
But the time that saved me was the time I was Chris Rock.
And my agent put his hands,
literally grabbed my nuts in a crowded party,
a Hollywood party.
Again, it's no different
than the Vanity Fair party or anything,
a big Hollywood event, Adam Sandler's party,
the head of the Motion Picture Department
at William Morris Endeavor,
this guy Adam Bennett gets high.
I don't know what he's on.
First of all, I know drunk, this wasn't drunk.
He's licking his tongue out at me.
He's acting all crazy.
I'd never met him before. I'd heard about him.
He's Sly Stalone's agent. He's Eddie Murphy's agent.
He's Sandler's agent.
He's head of the Motion Picture Department
at William Morris Endeavor.
Head. The man, okay?
The number one agency in the world.
And he comes over to me and I'm like, I stick my hand out,
like how you doing?
He grabs my nuts and with my wife right next to me
in a crowded party.
And basically, I'm the only black guy
in the party, by the way.
Everybody else is Hollywood royalty, right?
I pushed him back, like, what are you doing, man?
I push him into other people. It's so crowded.
I'm like, "Get away from me, man.
What are you? Hey!"
He's laughing. He comes back again.
I push him again. And I'm like, "What are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?"
I'm getting angry just thinking about it all over again.
And he starts to laugh like, ah ha ha.
Now I think, is there other people in on this?
Like here I am, the only black man in this party
and other people were there, other people saw it.
There are people who would never say anything,
but they were right there,
and they were all looking like,
and I thought they were in on it.
You start to think, am I the joke here?
Are y'all making like, was this planned?
Because it's just too bizarre.
Is this Jackass or something?
And y'all think this shit is funny?
And I said, "I'm gonna kill this dude."
Now, that's the next thought.
I was gonna put my fist through this guy's head.
And all of sudden I went,
I don't have to do that.
I don't have to do that anymore.
And I looked at my wife and you talking about years
of therapy already,
where you gotta understand in the black community,
if someone was to call you nigga,
the rule is to destroy them.
Like punch them, fight them.
Because if you don't, you quote unquote, let them do it.
Mm-hmm.
So the whole rule is that,
but once you examine that whole thing, I had to examine it.
And I said, but there are no niggers.
There's no such thing.
Am I a nigger? No.
So it's not an insult.
In fact, I can just let it go and count it to ignorance.
But the problem is, and where the real problem would lie
is if I really felt I was of true nigger.
All the insecurities, all that stuff would pop up
and then I would attack.
Same thing here. I'm not interested in this dude.
This is not anything I want.
So why would I get even get up?
Why would I have to kill this man?
But I did have to do something.
And I remember looking at my wife and she said,
she looked at me, I grabbed up their hand
and we left the party.
We got in the car, and now mindset,
I'm trying to tell you,
I had a thought of driving right back through the club,
(laughs) like Terminator.
You know what I mean? Ah!
But I went home and I couldn't believe.
I was degraded, dehumanized.
It was emasculation of the highest degree,
because here this was my own agency.
And then I didn't know who was in on it.
Like that was another thing I was like,
is this Sandler's thing?
Is this, you know, I mean, you know,
your mind just starts to race.
Yeah.
Like what is happening here?
That's assault.
What interesting,
I mean, look, we all read about this
and are aware of kind of what happened on some level,
but in the book, like,
I don't know how many pages you devote to it.
It's like 15 pages.
I mean, you go through the whole thing
and I learn much more about how it all transpired.
And one of the really interesting aspects of this story
is like, not knowing who to trust.
Yeah.
Like, can I tell my manager?
Can I tell this other agent at the same agency?
What is the head of the agency gonna say, or do or not do?
Yeah.
And it's this all,
you know, basically the peril
with which you have to, you know, figure out
what the right moves are because your career
and your future is on the line,
depending upon what you say or don't say.
But think about the Academy Awards.
Chris was all by himself.
Nobody ran over to him.
He was standing there, totally beat up,
face still red, still stinging,
and no one went over to him.
They went to Will, they went over there.
They went to Will and said, "Are you okay?
Are you all right?"
No one checked on Chris.
That's where I was.
Mm-hmm.
I'm sure Chris was like, well, who do I trust now?
Where am I? What the hell was that?
But imagine had Chris fought back,
it would've descended into chaos.
Oh my God.
It'd been the end of Hollywood as we know it.
Yeah.
And I think he saved everything.
See, that was that measure of composure
for him to even joke about it for him to just keep
his cool and just relax in that moment.
I thought, that's tough.
Like that's the essence of true toughness.
Again, the joke, should he have said it? No.
I don't think, it was a bad joke.
It wasn't even funny, but he didn't deserve that.
Yeah.
He didn't deserve that at all.
But I can tell you this, I was Will at one time.
Where you're out of control and wait,
all that had to do, that was going on in will.
Like that was going on in his,
you saw there was more going on there
than that joke.
Yeah. Oh, of course.
(laughs) You know what I mean?
It was like watching this man-
I mean, it's like the Zapruder film.
You could break this thing down,
you know, look at it.
Haw, that was me!
All that stuff that's going down.
I didn't beat that guy down for disrespecting wife.
It was something else.
You don't pick a guy up and slam him on his head
on the concrete for that.
It was something in me.
Didn't have anything to do with him.
And there's many, many times I would just smack people
and do stuff because I had this inner anger
that I did not control.
And it's so vicious and so crazy and insidious.
And it sneaks up on you at the...
like I promise you Will did not plan that out.
Of course not.
Okay?
It's like going into a blackout.
Blacked out.
And you knew when he was like,
"Get my wife's name out your fucking mouth."
I mean, we were all like, holy, this dude is lost.
He's having a meltdown.
But I knew that guy. That was me.
You couldn't calm me down after stuff like this.
And this is where my wife had to come and say, look man,
if you ever do this, man, and see,
then I have to tell everybody, 'cause what was wild,
'cause in my community, in the black community,
they were like, you should have knocked the guy out.
Sure.
That's the rule.
And you know, you're like the prototype alpha.
How could this happen to you?
You're too big.
I mean, you do a million takes on this whole thing.
But can I ask you this,
would you have believed my story
had I had knocked the guy out?
I don't think anybody would.
I just, you're at a party.
Terry Crews knocks out the head
of the Motion Picture Department because he, what?
Mm-hmm.
Terry probably had some drinks.
Yeah.
He probably didn't...
Listen, I don't drink. They be like, oh no.
Yeah right.
Yeah, you just decided,
maybe they did something you didn't like,
but there's that mean thug, Terry, we've been waiting on.
'Cause I got a whole record of you beaten up people.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, conversely, what would've happened had Will Smith
walked on stage and just said,
"Hey Chris, you know I love you,
but that was out of line, you know?"
And just handled it with composure.
He would've been this unbelievable hero.
Imagine if you'd put it in his acceptance speech-
Right, just waited until then.
What Chris said about my wife, man,
you know, it was over the line,
but I'm here to accept my...
And it would've been hero.
Right. Right.
But let me tell you what Hollywood's about,
and this is where me and Hollywood have always been at odds.
The head of the motion picture,
the head of William Morris Endeavor
told me he could get away with it.
I had a private meeting with him.
It's all in the book.
And I said, "Hey man, you don't get to molest the clients
and go to work the next day."
He said, "Yes, he can."
And he said, "What I'm gonna do is take his title
and suspend them for 30 days."
And I said, "Man, hey man, you gonna give him a vacation?
What are you talking about?
You can't molest the clients.
What are you doing?"
It was the same as the standing ovation for Will.
And I went, I said, "Dude, what are you talking about?"
I handed him a letter.
I grabbed his letter that he wrote
demanding that Mel Gibson be kicked out of Hollywood.
He wrote it for The Huffington Post for antisemitic remarks.
I said, "Look, you said, Mel Gibson
needs to be kicked out of Hollywood forever
for these remarks.
But antisemitic remarks, as reprehensible as they are,
they are not illegal.
What your man did is a crime.
And you're telling me it's different?"
He said, "It's different, Terry."
I couldn't believe it, dude.
I just said, and that's the rules.
See the rules of Hollywood is
call it out until it happens to you. (laughs)
You know what I mean? Cancel anybody else.
But us? No, no, not at all.
(Terry claps)
'Cause we meant well.
Right, well, and then you pursue,
you file criminal charges,
even knowing like that's probably not gonna go anywhere,
and then the civil suit, which ultimately doesn't
look like it's gonna go anywhere until a couple other dudes
come out of the woodwork.
That's right.
And then it's a whole different thing.
Whole different story.
And some females.
Mm-hmm.
Guys and girls. It was crazy.
But if I hadn't gone public,
it would've never brought the real people out,
and they wanted to join my case privately without,
you know, saying their names and the whole thing,
and I respected that.
But the thing was is that they were willing
to go to the mat for this guy.
And it was so foul and so corrupt,
'cause you gotta understand about Hollywood.
I mean like Harvey Weinstein would lead, you know,
all these women in Hollywood parties at his house
while he was raping them.
Mm.
You know, and this is the thing, you're talking about...
One reason I wrote the book was that I noticed
that there was things where success
is the warmest place to hide.
You know, it's a great place 'cause you don't,
no one calls you on your shit.
No one, because you're the man. You're Will Smith.
You're the head of the Motion Picture Department.
And when what we need, 'cause we talk about values,
we can say values,
but unless you actually act on those values,
it means nothing.
Ultimately money and power rule.
And in the case of this Adam Bennet thing,
it wasn't until money and power were threatened
that you were actually able to move the needle.
And what's interesting is that typically in these cases,
then it then becomes about how can we discredit
the person going after us?
Yeah.
But because you had done all that inside work
and kind of owned up publicly and privately
to the stuff that they would've been able to hang over you-
Yeah.
There was a freedom with that, right?
Where you were like, come at me.
That was, again,
when you're talking about gratitude,
I'm beyond thankful for that D-Day,
for that moment when I saw myself as I really was,
because if I hadn't,
liked you could ask me like, where do you think you'd be?
Oh my God. You know, running, hiding.
Imagine.
I would've had no strength to do anything,
to even come up against something like that
had I had secrets like that.
'Cause they would've found stuff.
Well and had you not unpacked those secrets,
you would've cold-cocked the guy.
Right and then-
But you might not have even been at that party
to begin with, but-
See, we can keep going.
You know what I mean?
(Rich laughs)
It's kinda like it could have been over before that.
It could have been...
But where the question really is
is where would the fall have come?
That's really what we're talking about.
Like what would've taken me out, you know?
'Cause all of this, any of this deception
that I was living was going to take me out some way,
shape or form.
Right.
And I'm gonna tell you, man,
that's where gratitude comes in for me right now.
'Cause I'm just like, oh, if I hadn't have done it,
I just thank God.
So I'm just thankful for my wife.
I'm thankful for my family.
I'm thankful for the people who did stick with me.
'Cause it was a very lonely time during that period.
There were camps and people were like,
what is Terry talking about?
And in my own community, I was looked at as a pariah
for even technically joining Me Too,
which they thought was a female thing, until all these men.
I mean we had wrestlers and pro athletes
that came out about, you know.
The fact is there's a organization called 1in6
that talks about one and six men
have been sexually molested at some time in their life,
and wait, and don't even acknowledge it.
Some they've been in military and whatever.
And they just called it,
well, the guy was goofing around, but you've been molested.
Yeah.
That line was crossed.
And if you don't unpack that and deal with that,
you're gonna act out in some way
that is not in service to you or others.
Prison is full, full of people who were,
at one time or another, used and abused in that way
and acted out in some of,
but would never, ever tell what happened to them.
And because I mean, that's why, you know,
you doing what you've done is so powerful
and palpable because you are cut from this cloth
of the ultimate, you know,
you've got this incredible physique
and this incredible career,
and as such for you to be able to come to the microphone
and talk about these things, I think, gives permission
to all of these people who are harboring
these stories with shame and in secrecy.
I'll tell you this, I will say,
my greatest accomplishment
beyond film, beyond movies
and TV and all this stuff, was when I got to team up
with Amanda Nguyen and she is the founder of Rise,
which we was all about passing
the Sexual Assault Survivors' Bill of Rights.
Because the thing is that whoever the perpetrator is
has tons of rights.
And she found that anyone who was a victim
of these things had no rights at all.
And I joined up with her and we went to Congress
and what was wild is that she had always
brought women there to talk.
And it was never a big, it never got that much light,
and by having a man there, it was packed.
That room was full. It was on CNN.
It was the highlight, and people were like, wait a minute.
And I look at that and I could feel the millions
and millions of people who never got the tell.
Dude, it was, I don't even how to describe it
because it's something that,
it comes with so much shame, you know, societal shame.
But I said, I have nothing to be ashamed of.
And I remember this was my log line
during this whole time, I was like, I will not be shamed.
I did nothing wrong.
And I had to repeat that because you feel like,
ooh, people don't even want to touch it.
They were like, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I said, "I will not be shamed. I did nothing wrong."
And this is what happens to people
who are victim or victimized.
I am no longer a victim.
I feel like now, you know, there's a point
where you grow past and you decide to grow
and you decide to move.
I was victimized, but no longer.
But to just be there and feel that from so many people,
that energy was like, finally, finally,
someone could come from forward and say this.
It was my calling.
And I said, "This is the most important thing I'll ever do."
Yeah.
Ever.
Yeah. That's really beautiful.
You've been very generous with your time
and I wanna let you go, but I can't let you go
without one final thing that I wanna talk with you about,
which is this quote that I love that I've heard you say,
which is, "In order to have, you must do."
Yes.
"And in order to do, you must be."
Be.
There's so much in there, man.
Oh man.
Like, this is the keys to the kingdom.
It is. It is.
In my opinion.
Let's close it out with a few thoughts on what that means.
And-
Oh man.
How that idea has been transformed of in your life.
You know, I am an idealist,
and I think it comes
with being an artist or just seeing a vision
and just seeing a better way and then going,
oh, I want to go.
I want that, you know.
And the thing is that for me,
what was my wild is that I always thought things
were impossible or I thought it was magic, you know,
but what I began to do is in order to be the person
I wanted to be, I had to say like, I have it already.
Like in order to be, to have the money and be,
let's say, consider yourself a rich person.
You have to look at the riches you have
and say, I have this, you know,
and to order to have you must do.
And then once you say, I have this,
you do the things a rich person would do.
And all of a sudden you are.
But remember that when in my mom's religion,
the do part was gone.
It was gone.
And I realized that in the action, first of all,
the visualization and then the action,
and then there it is, it comes.
And it's almost like, I say,
you don't know you're in Los Angeles, but you are,
you know, somebody just closed your eyes,
blindfolded you, plopped you right there in it.
You all of a sudden would have to know, like, you know,
you would have markers and different things
and all this stuff, but the realization
is that you are there and you have to be there now.
And then you behave like there now.
Right.
Dude, it's a deep thought.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You own that truth.
It just hasn't happened yet.
Like my friend Jesse Itzler, he has a quote
that he used to, a mantra that he would repeat
to himself when he was a young person.
Like I'm a millionaire.
They just haven't paid me yet.
(Terry laughs)
But like, you know, that idea applying to everything,
you know, you just intuit or you inhabit the idea
of what that, who that person is
who has the thing that you want,
or is living the life that you want,
and you then conduct yourself accordingly.
Let me tell you, a perfect example
is the first time I tried to quit porn,
you like, this is the hardest thing ever.
Like, what am I gonna do?
I remind you, I had three different jobs.
I started working like crazy,
'cause I was like,
what am I gonna do with my time,
(laughs) you know?
Yeah.
But it was hard because I was like,
this was what I used to do.
And when I didn't do it anymore,
the habit for doing something had,
you don't get rid of things, just replace them.
And I started to replace it with good things
and all of a sudden,
I didn't have any desire for it anymore.
But I can't mark the moment. I can't mark the time.
It was 12 years.
But then all of a sudden you go, I don't need that.
That's not me anymore.
I'm a whole nother person.
And it's so incredible.
It's almost like going back
through those Franklin planners and realizing,
wait, you saw yourself there.
You're even past that. You know what I mean?
Yeah, but it's also the difference
between white knuckling it,
like I'm gonna apply my self-will to this problem.
And just like, I am not gonna do thing,
versus like I'm letting go.
I'm transcending this
because I am becoming this other person
who wouldn't do that.
Let me tell you.
And that is a great thing,
because I have to tell you this,
because willpower doesn't work.
Doesn't work. Believe me.
I tried the first time I was getting out of it.
You're like, ugh. You're like, no, it's ridiculous.
But what I realize is that it's not a willpower issue.
It's a lack of information issue.
The more you start to realize and know, it changes you.
Like, when you know what it's doing,
when you know what it's costing, you know,
I did things like making logs
of how much I spent on all that every day.
And you think if you didn't write it down, you'd go,
"I spent 20 bucks."
When I actually wrote it down, it was $300.
And you go, what in the world?
But you, you can't rely on our intuition that way.
You have to start to really write it down and see it.
And the whole thing, and the willpower does not work.
It's gotta be the info, the info.
What is it I don't know?
And once you start going at like that, you know what.
You try to lose weight, you know what to eat.
You know what causes you to do these things.
You know what exercises to do,
you know what to be, and it's so,
and all of a sudden it changes you.
You wake up and you're just different
'cause you know more and you're responsible for more.
The more you know, the more you're responsible for.
Mm.
And so it makes it an amazing, I like to call it,
it moves from a toilet into a tornado.
Mm.
The spin just starts to go up and up and up and up.
(Rich laughs)
You know, the toilet is the other way,
you know, but the tornado,
it gets better and better and better.
That's great.
I love it, man. I love it.
Any final thoughts on somebody who might be listening
to this or watching this who is caught in some form
of compulsion or addictive behavior
and is having trouble knowing they need
to put it in the rear view mirror,
but can't seem to get out of their own way.
Let me tell you, my best advice,
period, is find someone you love and trust
and really, really believe in and tell them.
Most addictions thrive in secrecy.
That's it. I'm telling you.
It's, the secret is the killer.
Once you know, I went public on Facebook live.
Yeah.
(Terry laughs)
That's, I think, done like hundreds of millions of views
now at this point, or some crazy
amount like that, right?
Oh my God. Worldwide.
When I did that, the world shook.
But I did that to kill it for good.
Shame can't survive the light.
It can't.
It's like exposing the germs to sunlight,
and dude, but see, I wouldn't say,
and I would never, never, never suggest
that you do this publicly.
Do it with people you don't trust.
(laughs) Right. Usually it doesn't work out.
No, I was built for that.
I was in that mold,
but actually I'd already been through past that point.
And I went public just even to help other people.
But when I got public with my family
and I got public,
when I started to voice that I had an addiction,
I started to voice what the pornography thing was,
and I started to talk,
it loses its power, slowly but surely.
The fact that you can talk about your alcoholism,
it takes the power away from it.
And so anyone who's going through this,
the more you find someone you trust
that you can share these things with,
it slowly starts to real.
It's just, I like to say it shrinks and it gets cleaned out.
But the secrecy man, oh, everything grows
in secret, dude.
Yeah.
Everything. You lose total control.
And the more secrets you keep...
That's one reason why I'm so vulnerable.
'Cause I don't want, I don't want any secrets.
I just don't. I don't want any more.
I tell the whole story and man, I'm in control.
Right.
I feel totally in control.
It's the ultimate weight loss.
You know? (laughs)
Yes it is. (laughs)
You wanna feel lighter in your skin.
It feels so good, man.
I like to call it being one person.
Remember it was the image Terry,
and then it was backwards, and there's no,
nothing feels better than being one person.
Like, I mean what I say, I say what I mean.
It's so refreshing and I have no,
there's no guilt, there's no...
It's like being debt free.
Right.
You know what I mean?
It just feels like no, I don't owe anybody.
Yeah.
It feels good.
Amazing, man. Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Appreciate you Terry Crews.
Aww.
That was unbelievable.
Oh.
What a gift.
I enjoyed this man.
Thank you, man.
It was great.
I enjoyed it.
Thank you for having me.
Of course, everybody pick up Terry's new book, "Tough,"
available wherever you buy books.
And Terry's pretty easy to find on the internet
(Terry laughs)
and track down.
If you haven't heard of him, I'm sure you already have.
And also "America's Got Talent" is coming back this summer,
at some point
That's right.
This summer, May 31st.
May 31st.
All right, so will be in your household worldwide.
That's it.
And I'm gonna get shit because like you were here
for over two hours and we didn't even talk
about the fitness stuff?
Ah! (laughs)
Or intermittent fasting or anything like that?
So I might have to get you to come back here. (laughs)
We might have to come back. Yeah, yeah.
Do your best, you know.
Do a five-minute workout.
It's what you gotta do.
There you go.
Good times. Appreciate you.
Thank you.
Thank you, my man.
Much love. Peace.
(gentle music)